- Nice cock.
- Cum.
Cyberpunk music.
- There's just some memes
that just like transcend time.
- Harambee!
- I still laugh at
Uganda knuckles meme man!
That will never not be funny to me.
(upbeat music)
- I showed Joey that I slammed my penis
in the car door meme today.
- I don't understand that one.
- It's not about understanding.
Half of the meme is right,
that's how it always starts though.
You don't understand the meme
when you first get introduced.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But you understand it
through a weird repetition
and kind of mutual respect of
not really understanding
what the fuck is going on.
- [Joey] Right!
- But it's kind of funny.
- But like you know,
most memes, it's like you
can change it up a bit.
You can make a derivative.
I dunno how much you can derive.
(Joey chuckles)
- You'll be surprised.
It's like the whole
steamed hams thing, right?
- That's true.
- It can be pushed as much as it wants to.
By the way,
welcome to this episode
of the Trash Taste Show.
I don't know app your own.
Not that we say that-
- But The Trash Taste Show!
- You Trash Taste Show.
- Trash Taste Show!
(all chuckle)
- I guess we just found
ourselves in a topic
before we even like started the show.
- But welcome, I'm your host Connor,
with the boys, Joey and Garnt.
- Call the segment, Nice Kong.
- In the time that--
- No, we don't do that.
- 'Cause like going back to the memes,
I don't understand why I
find things funny anymore.
(Joey laughs)
Sometimes I don't know why
bass-boosted things are funny,
but like, it just appears
in the meme sometimes,
so I just like laugh.
- I think we're slowly
breaking down the human psyche
and the human consciousness,
and what is objectively funny.
And for some reason seeing an Orangutan,
and some men going, "Oh, oh, stinky!"
seems to always make me laugh,
and I can't tell you why.
There's no deeper meaning,
I'm just fucking stupid
and I've been hacked by this system
that somehow works against me.
- It's just like perfect science
of just like the right noises
and the right image you know.
- You know it's bad
when I could show that to a five year old
and they would be unamused,
but I'm there just pissing myself,
like crying, laughing, and it's like,
"What has happened?
Have we been hacked in a way that
like allows our brain to
revert to like one years old
and find things funny?
'Cause I don't know anymore.
- I don't know, I feel like the internet
just like broken our sense of humor.
Like why is the peak of internet comedy
just perfectly cut screams?
(Joey laughing)
- That is just like--
- That will never not be funny.
- I know, but why is it so funny?
- I don't know.
- Like I hear a scream, I sleep.
If you cut it just once
like a millisecond in,
it's fucking like comedy genius.
- Because imagining the
disaster is way funnier
than seeing a disaster.
- Yeah, that's what it is.
- Like it's like,
you've probably seen a
lot of the videos, right?
Where there's like a punchlines,
where people use like massive explosions.
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah.
- It's like the punchline.
But you never think like,
so like what was that explosion?
(all laugh)
- Was that a--
- What was blowing up?
- Did people die?
(all laughing)
Like, you know, you like,
"Ha ha, explosion go blow!"
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- True, true.
- Stuff is way funnier
when you can imagine what happens almost
in some aspects, right?
- What do you think is a meme
that you'll find funny
again in five years?
- Any Wiii sports meme for me.
(Garnt laughing)
Like at the moment that
music starts playing,
I'm like, before the joke even starts,
the moment I hear the music,
it's already funny.
- I'd like to think when I'm 50 years old,
that there's somebody I can go to,
and I'll be like, what's 9 plus 10.
(Connor chuckles)
And then they'd be like 21.
(all laughing)
And I'd be like, "Yeah!"
- Yeah, my man!
(all laughing)
And then we'll like, you know what I mean.
The same way that my parents
mentioned some weird
'60s BBC show that I--
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, I know
the spotted thing, yeah.
I'd like to think that's what
it's gonna be like, you know.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- They'll be like, "So no head."
And I'm like 60 and I'm
like pissing myself.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I don't know.
- We're in this weird time
where I think humor is gonna
be so fucked and liked!
- Oh yeah!
- I mean it's fucked month by month
let alone what is going to be like
in like one or two years.
- I don't know.
- It's gonna be like some
Morse code jokes or something.
- Yeah probably.
(all laughing)
- We're just gonna hear
(Joey mimics)
and just fucking piss ourselves off.
- It's gonna be visual like a braille.
It's gonna be like, "And then he said..."
and it's like just braille on the screen.
And we're gonna be like pissing it,
and it's gonna be like--
(Joey laughs)
- That sounds like a hilarious meme.
- That could be a meme.
(all laughing)
This is why memes are going now.
- Base-boosted braille?
(all laughing)
- I'm laughing at the thought
of shitty memes, you know.
- Base-boosted braille!
- Can you imagine that?
(all laughing)
- And then he said, brrrh!
- [Connor] And this is the thing--
- The idea of that just
sound hilarious to me.
- Can we just go with the new meme?
- I think it weird.
(Garnt laughing)
- And it's weird
because being friends with
someone like Chris, right?
- Yeah.
- Chris is just on the...
Chris in the weirdest spot I think.
Because I've shown memes to Chris,
where Chris will break down laughing.
- Yeah.
- And they're absolutely stupid.
But I've also showed him memes where
his boomer side comes out.
- [Joey] Right?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- And he's definitely like, "What is this?
What is this nonsense?
Why is there flashing
noises and deep fried?
What is that, what is...?"
You know what I mean?
Like Chris is at that
really interesting spot
where he's like,
Chris can be a boomer when
he wants to be a boomer,
but he also enjoys Gen Z
humor when he wants to.
- Yeah, that's true.
- And I find that really interesting.
Because I'm totally like,
my humor is so fucked now.
- Yeah.
- I can only laugh at stuff
when it's like bass
boosted and farting noises.
I don't know.
(Connor and Joey laughing)
(Cross-overs)
I feel like I'm a child, I'm a child.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
I feel that.
Because it's gotten to a point
where I don't know why I
find the things I do funny,
I just know I find it funny.
And there's no like formula to it.
There's nothing I can
break down to be like,
"Ha ha, that was why the
punchline was funny." You know.
- You can't explain
half the memes any more.
- But the problem is this,
if you have a favorite comedian,
you can be like, watch
their standup special.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- If I find like base-boosted,
(Connor laughing)
Daffy Duck slamming his
penis in the car door
with prapid rapid there.
How the fuck do I begin
to explain what I'm into?
- Just send a YouTube link.
(Garnt laughing)
- But then--
- Trust me, this is 10
million views, it's funny.
- Here's the problem
with sending people weird
ass memes like that.
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah.
- It's like.
And I've had this,
'cause I've been on the
receiving end of memes--
- I think everyone has.
- Yeah.
- Where I'm like, what the fuck is this?
(Connor chuckles)
- And it's just as,
we've turned to comedy into
this weird kind of niche,
where it's like the equivalent of
liking some weird German techno band now.
And it's like,
that's what comedy is now.
- Because to get like a lot of
the most funniest memes to me,
it takes like 10 layers of meme levels.
- You gotta go deep.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's something that if you're
not invested in this one,
in like one meme aspect,
then you're just not gonna get the meme,
'cause it's joke can be random.
- The joke of the meme
is like a reference to
another joke and another meme,
and so on and so forth.
So it's like-
- What the fuck is this coffee, hold on.
What the...
Does your coffee tastes weird?
- Well, what does it taste like?
- [Man] Like, what's wrong with it?
- It tastes like coffee.
- What kind, is it instant coffee?
- [Man] No, it's not.
- Oh, it's very...
- Whoa, what the fuck?
- [Man] It's coffee that
Meilyne usually makes.
- Is it really?
- That's some bass-boosted coffee.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- This is what of described
as a crunchy coffee.
- Yeah.
- [Man] Let me see.
- Have you had this coffee before?
- [Man] No but.
- What did I do?
Sorry, sorry, that threw me off.
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah.
- Do you mind if I?
- Sure, go ahead.
- Go ahead.
- Coffee review with Nabi.
- Huh, it's very stale.
- What the fuck?
- It tastes stale, yeah.
- Did the Nespresso let us down?
What's going on?
Is it the milk?
- Just a betrayal--
- I'll go and check.
- Is it the milk?
- Get the operations, send in the press,
find out what happened here.
- It might be the milk.
- I'll go upstairs.
- Whoa, that's funky.
- Like I just don't bother
to try and keep up with memes anymore,
just because like...
It's like, I already thought
the fun in Uganda knuckles meme
went by so goddamn fast!
And now I've realized
that Ugandan knuckles
sticking around for a month,
was like a feed of accomplishment for me.
- I mean, I still find the
Ugandan knuckles funny.
- Yeah.
- I think five years ago,
it's even quite different
from how memes are now.
- [Joey] Mm!
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Now, I feel like,
okay, five years ago we had memes
and we had like three or
four that were pretty big,
and you wouldn't really
hear about other memes.
But now there's always like
10 memes going on at once,
maybe one of them will kind
of get somewhat mainstream.
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah.
- And even that I don't
even mean mainstream,
like normal audiences, I mean like--
- Like on the internet?
- The Twitter sphere--
- Yeah, yeah.
- Because there are so many memes,
like if you ever watched
Lessons in Meme Culture,
do you watch that channel?
- No.
- Guy discusses memes,
and there's like every
day there's a new meme.
- Yeah.
- But most of these memes
live and die in the week.
I don't consider them like memes.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, no, no.
- I'm like, if this is a niche thing
that gets used a little
bit in some communities
and it doesn't really take off.
I'm like, yeah,
you don't really keep up with this.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] Mm!
- Because it's scarcely
anything to give a shit about.
- Yeah.
- [Man] I found out why.
- Why?
- Because we're using almond,
Not soy milk.
(man chuckles)
- No!
- No, this doesn't taste like almond milk!
- [Man] No?
- I use almond milk with
my coffee all the time.
- [Man] That states says
almond, I bought almond.
- It's the coffee that tastes weird.
- [Man] Is it?
- I think it's the combination
of the almond and the coffee.
- [Man] Probably.
- Yeah, I mean like,
there are some memes that
you see and you're like,
this is gonna die off within two days.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Because I feel like if a
meme is too easily replicated
that your mom could do it,
then it's not a good meme.
You know what I mean?
- Also, I feel with like
some memes it's like, okay.
Like a video with like
10 million views pops up,
it's like, "Cool, that went viral."
But it's like, you can't
do anything else with it.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- So it just ends up being this one video
that has a lot of views,
and then it gets forgotten over time.
- I think a perfect meme, right,
is one meme when you initially
watch or discover it,
you think, "This is fucking stupid!"
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And then third time
you're like, "Yeah, okay."
- Have you witnessed a perfect meme yet,
as the meme master?
- I think vocabulary
does that quite a lot,
like the word like busing.
- Yeah.
- I actually despised it
when I first heard it.
Somehow it just grew on me.
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah.
- Right now I find it hilarious.
So I don't know why I
can't stop saying it.
They're like "deez nuts"
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like "deez nuts" is not funny.
Scientifically speaking
"deez nuts" is not funny.
- Speaking of some, I find hilarious.
But I'll fucking laugh.
(all laughing)
I will laugh every goddamn time.
- I'll find every any opportunity
I can to say "deez nuts."
- It's one of those memes where you laugh
and you like hate yourself over eternity.
(Joey laughing)
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- It's like dabbing.
- It's the modern equivalent
of whipping yourself,
but mentally, you're just like,
"Fuck! Got to have to
schedule a better help call
after this, fuck!"
- I feel like a lot of memes now
are also like platform dependent.
Like there are like so many
TikTok trends and TikTok memes
that are massive on the platform,
but we don't like get
exposed to it at all.
And feel like it's only like a
super, super, super big meme,
if it like goes off of the TikTok platform
and you see it on Twitter
or on like YouTube as well.
- Is Japanese TikTok good?
- No!
(Joey laughing)
- Because right and I know-
- Is TikTok good?
- Yes, I think TikTok is good?
- I'm gonna say this, right now,
before people go accuse me of being like,
"Oh, let's see what the
content gives you, blah, blah."
I downloaded TikTok, right?
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah.
- Fresh account.
- [Joey] Yep!
- The first thing I opened it,
so it knows I'm in Japan.
- It's automatically Japanese.
- It's automatically Japanese TikTok.
What do you think comes up?
And like I'm scrolling for a while,
- Well, my experience?
- Yeah.
- From my experience
it's just a lot of like
Japanese girls dancing.
- Goddamn it, that's all it was!
- Yeah, that's what it really is.
- All these are literally
Japanese women, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And yeah, they're very beautiful,
very attractive.
- Yeah.
- Not even dancing,
just like moving their arms slightly.
- They're just like...
- They normally have assets
that are bigger than normal.
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah.
- And that was all it was.
I scrolled through like 50 TikToks
and maybe out of the 50,
I didn't support any of
them, just scrolling,
brand new account, nothing.
All it knew was that I was probably male,
I'm guessing knew that from the app store.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] Sure, sure.
- And that's all it was.
- Yeah.
- And like, you'll enjoy
this type of content,
You're a Japanese male.
- And I was just like,
don't get me wrong,
there's a time and a place for this-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Grant] Yeah.
- I don't want this!
- Yeah.
- This is not want.
- I wanna see the memes.
- I'm not a kind of person, all right.
I don't know if this is
like a sigma male grind set.
I don't wanna see this...
- I hate how you said that.
- I don't wanna see like women or...
(Connor laughs)
That sounds so bad.
(all laughing)
- Go on, say it, say it!
- I don't wanna see women!
- I don't wanna shit that's
trying to make me horny
when I'm not horny, right?
- [Garnt] Right, right.
- If I wanna watch stuff like that,
I'm just gonna go and watch porn.
- [Joey] Yeah of course.
- It's very obvious what audience that is.
Am I allowed to say that,
that's like women just
dancing and showing off boobs.
- I mean, it's been like that
since the beginning of probably time.
- I'm fine with that content,
but I don't want that most of the time.
- Yeah, I mean--
- There's so much of that kind
of content you can consume.
- It's the same reason why
everyone hated the old...
Remember when like YouTube
went through this epidemic
of the "Reply Girls?"
- Yeah.
- Where it was just girls with--
- Scarcely kind clothes, yeah.
- Obviously I have absolutely nothing
against people who
wanna make that content.
- No, exactly.
- I support all that
stuff and any sex workers,
you keep doing what you wanna do, man.
I wish there was more protection
around stuff like that.
Obviously this isn't, it's very different.
But it's just for me personally,
most of the time when I see that stuff,
I'm not the audience
they're trying to appeal to.
Because I don't want to...
I don't see that stuff
and I'm not like, "Oh this
is the content I wanna see."
- Right.
- You're also not a
horny teenager anymore.
- Right, right,
but to me it's like as someone who is 25,
I'm doing my own thing and whatnot,
to me when I see a girl
dancing as a content creator,
I'm just like, "Okay, what
am I following for here?"
- Yeah.
- What am I...
If I wanna follow this creator
what am I coming back for?
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah.
- To watch them dance?
Like when it's not dancing,
it's not dancing
- And not even,
it's like your 50 year old adult dancing.
- They do this fucking
same thing every time,
they just go like this.
- [Joey] Yeah, it's like
you're 50 year old aunt
at a wedding.
- Yeah.
- It's just the bare minimum of movement,
and it's like this is dancing.
- Right, right.
Kind of this conversation
makes me sound so sexist,
I'm not trying to be.
- I don't know.
- But it's not the content,
we personally want to see all right.
- That's not even like
the worst kind of like...
How can I say?
I don't know what the genre is,
but like the sleazy bait or whatever.
I don't even know what the genre is?
Like I remember that--
- It's obviously sexual
and it's trying to appeal.
And anyone who sees the video
and says it's not sexual,
it's complete bullshit.
- [Joey] No, it is absolutely sexual.
- You know who you're appealing to.
- I mean it's very obvious that like,
at least in Japan,
and I assume with the
rest of the world too,
that like the main demographic of TikTok
is like teenage boys and girls.
- [Connor] Right.
- Yeah.
- So obviously, what are
teenage boys gonna enjoy?
- Sorry, (indistinct).
- That kinda sleaze fest.
- Because I remember like the other trends
that I saw in TikTok was,
it was like girls who are
obviously very confident
and you know, trying to...
No, what was I gonna say?
It was girls that had
this audio that played,
which was-
- It's like we're busing?
- No, no, no, no, it was like...
(Joey laughing)
That one's a good one.
- If we had 24 hours of me alone
and I couldn't say no,
what would you do?
And I'm just like--
- The meme are good with one.
- And I'm just like,
most of the memes I've seen with that,
are like parodies of that.
- Yeah.
- But that just means that
there are enough people
doing this unironically-
- Yeah.
- To parodies in the first place, right?
- That's why it's been parody so much.
'Cause it is obvious saturated,
and it is such it's bay.
- It's such sleaze bay, right?
- You know, and I...
Its this a new coffee?
Lets just give this a taste,
coffee gate Trash Taste.
- Coffee gate!
- [Man] Trash Taste coffee.
- Is it better?
- Still tastes funny.
(man chuckles)
I don't know what's happened.
There's something offensive.
I know I'm not offended,
but I'm like, "Come on, man!
Just because I log on the platform,
you've gotta show me this shit!"
- Yeah.
- "At least give me
something else to look at,
so you can kind of figure me out."
- Give a little bit of
variance in the content.
- I'm like, "Why are you gonna
assume what I'm into, man!"
Like yeah, "She's beautiful,
good for her, I'm glad she's killing it.
I'm glad she's got 20
million views every second,
good for her.
Why did you assume I was into it?"
- No, but that's the thing, right?
It's like, I wouldn't even be mad
if it was just popping up
every now and then, right?
It's like, yeah, of course, you know,
it has to appeal to that demographic,
but yeah, I had the exact same experience.
When I opened it,
it was like 49 out of 50,
which just different girls.
- I'm not mad,
'cause I don't want to be like headline,
"Man gets mad, that woman is dancing..."
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Like that's not it, but also--
- No but like, a little of variance
doesn't hurt anyone, right?
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- It just means like the algorithm
hasn't been tailored for you yet.
- Exactly, exactly.
- [Connor] But that's--
- Just like--
- That's kind of sad
that that's what it was.
Like if you were a new user in Japan
and I assume they know my
age and maybe my gender--
- Yeah.
- Or it just means like algorithmically-
- That's kinda content that works, yeah.
- So it's the best apparently.
And I'm guessing it's because
there's a certain age
range and a demographic
that the algorithm puts you in-
- [Connor and Joey] Yeah.
- And they're just like,
"This person wants to see
this kind of content."
- You wanna see horny content,
we got you, bro.
- And I mean, it's
everyone knows sex sells,
and it's always been that like that
since the beginning of man.
- I would very much like my
horny separate from my life.
- Yeah.
(all chuckling)
- I like it, when I-
- Tell that to the man who
likes Hentai on Twitter.
- I can look at Hentai, right?
And I can just be like," Nice!"
But I don't feel anything towards it,
but when I'm like, "All right,
I'm now gonna jack off."
Then I'm like, "All right."
- What do you think I'm jacking off
to everything I like Twitter?
- No, no, no, no!
(Joey laughing)
But that's what I mean.
- I'm just like, I'm
scrolling through like.
No, I don't know,
Yeah, no, but I'm the same, right?
It's like, "I don't like
all these like Hentai pics
on Twitter because I'm feeling horny."
I'm just like,
"Oh, that's cool art work!"
- I think, I don't know really.
Why is it...
'Cause when you see Hentai
you're like you're unoffended by it.
But sometimes you can see
someone trying to be sexy
and it could be annoying, I don't know.
- I think it's the difference between
just someone trying to be sexy,
and someone who's done
put art into it, right?
- Yeah.
- Because I think the same way
except when I see like
a fucking amazing cosplayer
player, for example.
- I love seeing cosplay.
- I love seeing great cosplay,
even if some of them are
like very suggestive.
It doesn't matter
because someone put work into this,
someone did a photo shoot,
and it's fucking great, you know?
And I feel like that is the difference
between just like seeing Hentai
or like really sexy
cosplayers on your timeline,
versus just seeing,
I don't know what's it, like sleazebag.
I'm just gonna call it that you know.
- Yeah, no, I get that, I get that.
- I mean, cosplay is amazing
and there's plenty of lewd
stuff out there that I enjoyed.
But that's why I like Twitter.
'Cause you can get like 50 memes
and a bunch of lewd stuff
all in the same place.
- Right, it has variance, right?
- Yeah.
- Maybe if I used TikTok more
and it figured out that
I liked some other stuff.
- [Joey] I'm sure, yeah.
- But I don't know why,
I was just kinda like, "Ah, ah."
I know on every ad in
Japan is like that as well.
I don't know if it's Japan,
it might be just Japan that's like this,
but like every ad I get in Japan as well
is like porn or like dating sites.
- Like dating sites, yeah.
- It is literally like,
the number one ad that I get on Twitter
is this one website,
where you can hire girls to speak to you.
- I've seen that one.
(Joey chuckles)
- And I get it all the time!
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I'm just like,
this is sad that this is
like the number one thing!
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I mean, that's a whole another thing
about loneliness in Japan.
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah.
Guys struggling like that.
- I genuinely don't even think like,
even after it gets tailored,
that that will go away.
Because I feel it's just the
main demographic in Japan--
- How much have you used TikTok?
Well I guess you use TikTok
more than either of us?
- I mean, when I say I'm on TikTok,
I'm not really like religiously on TikTok.
I just go onto it every now and then
when I'm like there's
nothing to see on Twitter.
But again, it's like,
I haven't used it enough
that I see a variance
of all sorts of content.
I'm still at that early stage
where I see 49 out of 50 girls dancing.
- Yeah, same here.
Which is why I found myself
watching more YouTube Shorts
because it seems,
most of them are just
recycled TikToks anyway,
but I already have a YouTube profile.
And so a lot of the
content is already tailored
to the stuff I've watched on YouTube.
And every time I log into TikTok,
I don't see a lot of these TikTok trends
that have just become viral.
Even though everyone seems
to be talking about them,
I'm just like,
"Well, it's not appearing on my timeline."
I dunno what my profile is set to--
- I take TikTok trends very lightly--
- Have you seen some of the latest ones.
Like, have you seen...
- Were about to date
this episode, but like.
- I remember a month ago,
I just wanted to die inside
because there was this trend
called like devious things or something.
- What?
- Which was just okay.
So devious licks are just people
who just went to like bathrooms,
and kids would start stealing
like the soap dispensers.
- Okay.
- And then it started off as that.
And then, you know how TikTok is,
you know the internet is.
It starts escalating
to the point where
people were just full on,
like, they're stealing like-
- [Connor] Sinks.
- Sinks, roadsigns,
and there's like people that
stole whole vending machines.
- Oh my God!
- Okay, hold on.
How the fuck do you
steal a vending machine?
- I don't know.
- How do you do that?
- I mean, you have to pray some
of the logistical abilities-
- Yeah.
- Pertaining stealing.
- But at the same time,
you're just combating like
almost Grand Theft Auto
and just putting out
on the internet to see.
- It was obviously stupid.
It was a trend that was widely condemned
whenever YouTube under then someone--
- [Joey] Oh yeah, of course.
- Made a video condemning it.
I mean, it's easy.
It's a slam dunk when your
YouTube would be like,
"Hey guys, stealing, bad."
Applause now please.
I will take my applause, you know.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- I just can't get over that someone
had the balls to steal a vending machine.
I don't even think repo
men are allowed to do that.
- Alright man, all the
trees will still get stuck--
- Yeah, that's true.
- I'm just more surprised
that just people were just stealing
and then filming themselves stealing.
- Yeah, well people aren't so small.
(Garnt laughing)
When clout is offered.
- Clout is offered.
- Clout is value, yeah.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- When clout is on the
table, anything goes.
- Yeah.
- Function like a normal
human being or prison time.
- Yeah.
- Did hear about a couch guy,
or the couch guy?
- No.
- This one's very familiar.
- That was the latest trend
as well I heard about.
- I'm scared to ask what that is.
- So it was this girl
who basically surprised visited
her boyfriend in college.
- Right.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And she walks in
and the guy, her boyfriend
is sitting on a couch
and he doesn't seem as excited
as maybe one would expect.
- Okay.
- So he acts a little
bit awkward, you know?
And he then he eventually
gets up and hugs her, right?
- Okay.
- And Twi...
I was gonna say Twitter.
TikTok takes us like 30 seconds clip
and was like, "He's cheating on her."
- They literally went like
full Netflix documentary,
true crime--
- Yeah.
- Were internet detecting.
- Analyzing the frame by frame.
And like, it was insane.
It was just like the worst
part of the internet.
- So was he cheating on her?
- No, they said no.
But they were like,
"Yoh! calm the down."
- Yeah.
- Big, big facts.
Maybe he wasn't just excited.
- No, no, exactly.
There could be so many ways
you could spin this narrative, right?
And they're all like,
"Literally people just full on projecting
their narrative towards
this 30 second clip."
Like I saw this one TikTok
that was just like,
the girl release a
statement that was like,
and she said,
"There's nothing more to this clip.
I'm friends with all the girls.
You don't need to worry about it.
I know the girls."
And this one woman posted
the TikTok being like,
"Girl, you don't need to worry.
You don't have friends
because I've seen friends like them.
They're not your friends.
Friends should be excited
when their friends steps into the room.
We've all been in that position."
I'm just like--
- Maybe she was just British.
- I'm just like, I know right?
- If there's anything worse
than an internet detective,
it's an internet therapist.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
Those are the worst.
Where it's like, "Let me tell
you why your wife's sucks."
You say it's great, but it doesn't.
Let me tell you why.
It's like, "Dude, leave me alone."
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it was just like,
there is no way you can break
down this much of a narrative
through a 30 second interaction.
- No, God no!
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- I mean, it's the thing
about the internet where--
- It's like some Zodiac killer shit.
- It is, it literally was.
- They found him out though.
- I was, have they found him?
- Yeah, they found him recently.
(all laughing)
- They found him, he died,
and he left a review for the movie.
- Did he?
- Yeah.
- He left a review for the Zodiac--
- Wait, is this confirmed?
- Yeah.
- How did they find him?
- Ah, there was, oh, I think--
- He died in like 2017 or something.
- Yeah.
- They quite awhile about.
- I can't remember how they found him,
there was some scars.
I can't remember exactly,
it doesn't really matter.
They found him basically.
And then he left her...
I don't care how they found him,
I wanted to know what he
thought about the movie.
(Joey laughing)
And he left a review on the IMDB page.
- Really?
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- Did he say it was good or?
- I think he didn't like it.
(all laughing)
I don't know, that's just right
kind of funny even though.
Makes murder reviews his own movie.
I don't know why, I was just like...
- Jesus Christ.
- Oh, wait, before we move on,
I forgot to give you
something last week Joey.
Me and Sade got a bunch
of omiyage for everyone.
And I said to Sade,
I was gonna give this
to you on the podcast,
but here's some tea.
- I've got some tea.
(indistinct)
- I gave him to me last week off camera.
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- I'm tryna shield my friendship.
(Garnt laughing)
- Well, that's perfect
'cause you gave me cookies.
Garnt gave me tea,
sounds like a perfect combination.
- Cookies biscuits.
- Biscuits whatever.
- No, because do you
know what I've realized
after like buying omiyage for people
from like English omiyage.
- [Connor] Oh very cute.
- Very cute.
- So tea set.
- Nice, thanks man.
- Yeah, no worries.
- Because what I've realized--
- We're friends, we're friends.
Guys analyze that click, analyze it all.
Analyze that frame by frame.
Well, Jowey wasn't excited (indistinct)
- Joey wasn't that excited.
'Cause I mean, there's,
there's some going on.
There's some going on.
- He's definitely cheating.
- You tell a lie, you choked.
But I mean, there is some
kind of truth in that,
in some aspects I have
seen people on Reddit
or the comments,
super analyzing our reactions
to things like what?
I can't remember.
This there's been a lot though.
There's like, oh, wow.
It kind of seems really centered today.
- Yeah but Redit it's like a free
when it comes to that
kind of stuff, we just.
Say what they want.
- It's interesting though.
Seeing how people perceive us sometimes
and sometimes in a good way,
sometimes in a bad way.
- That doesn't everyone always say
that you always look angry
or likes Ty.
- Yeah.
Everyone was like, oh, I am tired.
A lot of the stuff that's.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I have to, I wake up early,
but you know, yeah.
Some people like he's angry
and I'm like, no, I'm just,
I just tired.
- This is resting face.
- You'll know if I'm angry.
- Yeah.
(Connor laughs)
- Will you, maybe you're there.
- I dunno.
- I'll storm off.
I just won't be here.
(Connor laughs)
Oh yeah.
I (laughs).
- Yeah.
No, but like, yeah, read it.
I've seen some stuff on
Reddit where it's like,
wow, you got it.
Ain't that deep, bro.
Like, you didn't have to go to that.
- It's difficult because on one aspect,
I understand that all they have to go off
of ours is our episodes.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Of course.
- And that's all they have to go off.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But I wouldn't, by any
stretch of the imagination,
say that trash taste is reflective of,
well, I just said is
reflective of who I am,
but you miss a lot of nuance.
Right?
Like it's very easy to
generalize who we are,
but also as a show.
Right.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah.
So here we are.
We do, I won't lie.
There's times where I'm like,
I'm going to keep this argument going.
'Cause it's great content.
- Yeah.
- A lot of the times I wouldn't,
some of the arguments I get
into with Connor or Joey
or not arguments I'd get
into with a random stranger.
- I would just get, I don't,
even though I do feel
strongly about a lot of things
as you guys know very well.
I also, in general life
just don't give a to argue.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I like arguing in this
space with the boys.
- I didn't even give a on the shot.
(all laughing)
(indistinct)
- The judges, Joe, just like trash tastes.
Like.
- I mean, with the guy in
the background with the bomb.
Just like I don't care.
- Sometimes I do like to go to explore
other sides of opinions as well.
- Yeah.
- But it also is like, if it is,
sometimes there are
controversial opinions.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But they are opinions.
And then they are sometimes
commonly held opinions.
And it's one of those things
where I would like to
play devil's advocate
in some situations without
having to be like Connor,
is that kind of person he's like...
- Yeah just to get conversation.
(indistinct)
- Yeah.
- You know, we've always said
we don't have to be a circle track.
- No, no.
- And I always want to be able
to talk about topics and say things.
- Yeah.
- It just makes more far more interesting.
- And you know, if anything,
I would wish that sometimes people
would like not assume exactly our thoughts
and opinions on things based
off the things that we're.
- Supposed to buy Harrys.
- Does, are you heading
back to the office?
Anytime soon.
- I'm in the office right now.
(all laughing)
- Tell him to get back fresh,
clean, and all shaven
looking business like,
and let Harrys help you get.
- If you don't know
Harrys it's time you do
because Harrys was created
to be hitting different from
other shaving companies,
little, little reference,
how always cross high quality,
long lasting blades and
durable weighted handles
that make a close,
comfortable shave quick.
And dare we say enjoy.
- Ooh,
because Harrys insists
that you shouldn't have to choose
between a great shave and a fair price.
They just give you both
refilling blade starts
as low as two box.
- Even easier.
New Harrys customers
get their starter set,
which includes a five blade
razor weighted handle firming
gel with Allo and a travel cover.
It's a $13 value all for just $3 43.
Is that a typo?
Typo, that is insane value.
And there are a bunch of other products.
And now I've actually used,
Harrys a bunch myself.
When I went to the UK,
when I was getting on the plane,
I actually saw Harrys in the store
and I wanted to buy more.
But there's no in Japan,
I've actually bought a bunch.
- You leach these stocks up on Harrys.
- So there's never been
a better time to try.
Harrys going to Harrys.com/trash
to get their starter set
for just three bucks.
It's 100% satisfaction guarantee.
So you've got nothing to lose.
Go to harrys.com/trash right
now to get its special offer.
- That's H A R R Y S.com/trash links down
in the description below.
Like (indistinct).
- Like one thing that I hate
about the internet, right?
And this is one thing
that I actually despise
about being an online creator
is that if I want to
talk bad about something,
I always have to preface it before.
Right.
And we did the study with the thing
with like me saying,
like, I don't want to see,
girls dancing that isn't
trying to entice, you know?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- I have to then preface that
by saying I support sex work.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And I think it should
just should be a given
that that's what's.
- (indistinct) think so.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- So that's the way I feel,
but it sucks the internet
that I have to always preface
that, okay, I support
this, this, this, but,
and I hate that fact
that I can't just talk.
I have to then be like,
go through the checklist.
Okay.
I want to talk about this stuff.
All right, cool.
I've got to make sure that
everyone knows that I support
this, this, this, this, this.
And it's like, no, no.
- You got a ride on
(indistinct) to fine prime.
- Just because someone
is always gonna assume
the worst of you.
They're always going to assume the,
what you're saying is the worst thing
and it's kind of a bad
place that they don't agree.
- Yeah.
- You can't, say anything
bad about something
that they agree with
because they don't want to hear it.
- Yeah.
- And you know, it's and
it's over the internet,
especially if it was in person,
they put you in a different.
- Yeah.
- Because that's the
biggest thing I've noticed
about speaking on line on the incident
and speaking to someone person
to person you like online,
you do have to preface a lot of things
because it seems like in person to person,
people are more willing to give you
the benefit of the doubt.
- 100%.
- Online people aren't willing
to give you the benefit of the doubt.
A lot of the times.
- I think the other problem
as well is that on the internet,
it's very much a one-way conversation.
- Yeah.
- So you have to give your
entire spiel all in one, go.
- Yeah.
- Otherwise, if they do reply back to you,
then it's not going to
be this conversation.
It's just going to be like shooting
the messenger kind of deal.
Right.
- Yeah.
- And it's like, it sucks
that on the internet,
common sense.
Isn't as common as people make it out.
- It's like, when we say bad
things about Japan, right?
That comes from a place of loving Japan
and being here for awhile,
we're here for a reason, right?
We like, we love this place
and we love living here,
but it sucks that every time this
and this has only happened
to Japan and the UK,
I never have to say, I love the UK.
Only with Japan.
Do you have to say,
I love Japan, but like,
because it has this weird stigma,
but there's a lot of topics
that you have to do that in the internet.
If you want to say anything bad about it,
you be like, I love this thing, but.
- Yeah.
- And if you don't say that
before, people are like,
(indistinct)
you come from a place of hating.
- Yeah.
- You know and it's so frustrating
that that's what it's become,
because I feel that there
are so many discussions
it's so bloated because you have to go
through the checklist of
all this fucking nonsense.
- That is the biggest difference
between us talking in a pub
and us talking on trash taste,
which we have the same
kind of conversations.
But it's like, you put your,
you putting yourself through a buffer.
- Yeah.
- Like have more safety net
of the things you're about to say,
whereas I wouldn't need
to do that if like,
there were no cameras filming.
- (laughs) Like putting on
the seatbelt, like this 50,
like the whole like way,
way back with the gambling episode,
right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like I never, ever once
thought for a second.
And we were doing that episode, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- This is, probably like
a quite well-known episode
amongst the viewers
that you guys were addicted to gambling.
- Right.
- I know you guys, you're
not addicted to gambling,
no point in your life.
Would I say you?
You know, and it was weird how,
because we didn't that,
'cause we didn't say because you,
even though you guys are
playing devil's advocate to me
and I was very much,
I was very much arguing
in Gacha specifically,
but there should be more regulation
and that it should be like that.
And you guys were just playing
devil's advocate with me,
right?
- Yeah.
- I know that you guys want
to take it to catch it,
but it was weird seeing
a lot of the comments,
just jump to conclusions and being like,
they must be addicted to
catcher because they don't agree
with Connor's opinion.
- Yeah.
- And it's like, all right,
you can, you can, you can be,
you can not gamble and not be a gambler,
but also think that catcher
doesn't need any more.
- If you don't specify it,
then they think that you're on
the very end of the spectrum.
You're not allowed to be.
- Yeah.
- It was just weird.
Seeing all the comments,
getting so aggressive about it.
Like people get like angry
about it and it's happened on a
few other apps.
- Yeah.
I mean,
I think like it kind of happened
quite recently with view
isn't it like the trip debates?
- Oh my gosh.
- I think, I think we,
I think the problem with that
was that we were arguing like
two different things.
- And so it was, that was a weird one.
- And people, people took me.
I was, 'cause I was trying
to argue that, you know,
you can have driven the matter
how much you pay for it or
how much is how much
the clothes are worth.
And you are arguing that, you know,
don't support fast fashion and
you know, try to, you know,
you try to buy things or
buy clothes that are more
sustainable in different environments.
And you care more about quality nowadays.
And people took that as wow.
Connor and Joey have
just like lost their way.
- Yeah.
People like wow is so privilege.
And by most metrics I am privileged.
Never.
I'm never pretending to be like, I live,
like I come from like a really far off,
I've never got tended.
And everyone's like, you
know, it was really weird.
That was because at no
point in that argument,
did I ever argue that that drip
had to be expensive clothes?
I,
my main argument was that the
word drip initially came from,
you know, when,
when you were like the rappers
who would wet grip and it was
all branded, it had to be branded.
You know, that was my argument.
And at no point did I ever
argue that cheap clothes didn't
look good?
But for some reason the common
section took me arguing that
I prefer quality clothes,
not looks quality.
Like I prefer stuff that lasts longer
than that damper support,
fast fashion and all that.
They were like, oh, well,
all these fast fashion,
all the high-end ones
are using slave labor.
Anyway.
It's like, well, you're
just generalizing it.
You're putting them all in the bubble,
but I never made that argument.
Right.
It was, really bizarre.
- Didn't you didn't,
I guess the issue was that
you didn't put that safety net.
- I never, and at no point
did I say drip has to equal money?
And that was the problem,
because I didn't say that people assumed
that I was thinking that
people have to assume,
and it wasn't even funny.
I said at one point,
Joey, he'd you watched it back,
Joey joked say, yeah, drip is expensive.
You were joking.
But Jerry, he was mainly me.
Wow.
I was like, what is happening?
And it was like, the
whole comment was like,
Connor's privilege is really
showing I'm like what?
And then like, man,
they think with a first-world mindset.
And I was thinking that like I was like
from a first world country course,
I'm going to think I'm
trying my best to learn
and to expand my horizons
and learn more about other countries.
But you know,
I'm obviously gonna think through
a first world perspective.
Like that's because that's my world.
Right.
I don't like,
is it wrong of me to
have that perspective?
I'm now because I.
- Feel that's the only.
Perspective I'm trying to
learn about other things.
Right.
- But I'm try to learn (indistinct)
- But in the case with that argument,
it's very difficult to bring
in a different perspective.
Right.
Without a making no sense.
- I mean, I think the argument is that,
you know, yes.
Do you support sustainable fashion,
but a lot of people from
third world countries
con you know, being able to sustain,
being able to support sustainable fashion
is in itself a privilege
because other people can't do that.
And you know,
some people will do at
the moment have no choice,
but to buy cheap fashion
because they can hardly.
- Well can never hold it against anyone.
You know, when I was buying
those, I mentioned like,
when I was buying the suit,
that was like 30 pounds.
Right?
- Yeah.
- That was because that
was all I could afford.
- Yeah.
- Right.
I didn't get, there was no other option.
I couldn't even like entertain
the idea of getting a suit that costs 100.
But obviously when you're doing better
and you have more income,
I do think it's more of a
responsible thing to do to try
and buy things more ethically.
- Right.
In that episode, you'd
never once said, yeah.
(indistinct)
- I remember seeing this
other argument of like,
well, they just overpriced
the clothes, et cetera,
et cetera.
And I, yeah.
Sometimes they do do that, but also, it's,
I've had this debate
coming from, you know,
doing voice acting a lot,
which is a job that takes
one hour most of the time.
- Yeah.
- And you get, you can
get paid like $10,000.
- Yeah.
- Most people would
think that's, we'd argue,
that's absurd.
You should never get paid that much
for one hour of work.
But it's what goes into being
able to do it in one hour.
The reason why I could do that in one hour
is because I'm trained
and I can do the job professionally.
I know how to use the equipment.
I know how to do everything in a way
where you couldn't just take someone,
you get the quality of sound, right.
You get, somebody who can do the quality
that you want within
one hour in a professional way.
And it's the same way with close to me.
Like, if I want a suit,
if I am in a good enough position
to be able to afford a suit,
that is a nice suit and I can get it made
for me specifically.
Right.
And get it.
'Cause I got it.
I have the problem though,
that I have short legs, massive.
So pants don't scale like that.
They scale wide and down I,
the pants I have to get like fitted
because my, just
(indistinct)
so like that was always a challenge.
Right.
I always had jeans that were
either too short or too tight.
Right.
And I still have that problem
because you can't get tailor,
fit jeans, they probably can't,
but it's a real easy to get fitted.
- Yeah.
- So I think as well, like,
so if you were to get, like,
let's say you go to a tailor, right.
You're paying a tailor
who knows how to do it.
Well, he's done this for like 20 years.
He's experienced his whole life.
He can promise you that
he'll do a good deal.
It's worth the extra money.
If you have the money and you know,
you can support a local
business if it was one.
Right.
I think if you, again, this is
only if you have the luxury,
like it's, it's certainly a
privilege you want to do that.
And I would never,
ever get anyone's case for not doing that.
- I mean...
If you gotta, you gotta do
what you gotta do to survive.
Right.
Everyone else.
- I think it's like,
what I don't understand is
the criticism towards like how
you spend your own hard earned money.
It's like, it's like,
I earned that money myself.
I'll do with that money.
However, I please.
- That's a good point as well.
Like.
- Taking care of my finances.
It's like, why you care.
- You can't listen.
The only,
the only questionable decision
I make is my Jojo collection.
Right? That's the, I'll
give you props for that.
But everything.
I'm pretty.
I compare us to other YouTubers.
I think we're pretty normal.
Whereas you have a Lambo
garden when I rent a car,
you know what, like,
you know what car I rent a Toyota Yaris.
(all laughing)
I love the Toyota guy.
It is on my couch on
that car is fantastic.
It's perfect size.
It's not too big.
- We don't.
We don't even own cars.
(all laughing)
(indistinct)
- I take the train everyday.
- It's I hate this thing
where people are like,
they judge us for what we're
fucking doing with our lives.
And it's like, bro, just like,
I don't come to your house
and be like really hot
pockets cringe, bro.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- We got cheese puffs.
Like, no, what?
Like what is this?
- Yeah.
'Cause, like you're going
back to what you were saying
about getting paid for like
doing an hour of voice.
It getting paid like a certain amount
that voice actors do get paid.
And I give this example to
like every artist, right.
Or every, anyone working
in that kind of field,
which is you go to you,
then you have to ask the client then.
Okay.
So would you rather pay the same amount
for me to do this work
in five hours or in 10 hours
to get the same amount of work?
And if they say yeah or no,
then you can say that.
Okay.
So I'm being punished for,
do my job well efficiently
in this time period.
So you'd rather pay someone
else to do the same work
for more time.
Even though you're paying them for like,
you're paying for the same amount of work,
but you're paying them to do
it less efficiently than you.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But like the perception is that
because you're doing it this well,
you're giving them the same amount of work
for a shorter period of time.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- That you're charging that much.
And that's just how the industry is.
You know, you're not just
paying for hours, worked in.
- Yeah.
- You're paying for skill as well.
And skill is part of the
pricing that you pay.
- Yeah absolutely.
- And also, when it's these
big advertising companies,
in what realm is it fair for your voice?
Be plastered over same.
McDonald's all over the country.
- Yeah.
Its a branding issue.
- You got a brand like,
it's a using your voice.
So you have a certain right to,
to sell that what it's worth.
Right?
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
There's a lot of jobs like that.
Like, you know, like the
art, like art design,
graphic design, anything, it's, if it's,
if it's although like
stuff like voice acting,
I 100% admit,
like it seems very easy from the outside,
but to be able to do it consistently
and perform what the person wants
and be able to adjust
and be able to do it all professionally,
it's very difficult.
- And to be able to do it
over and over (indistinct).
Build the reputation.
- You've got a long way to go, man.
There's people who are much
better than me who can do it,
but you know, at the end of the day,
you want to make sure
everyone's getting the right.
Right.
- Yeah.
- It's yeah.
It's, one of those tough decisions.
Money is always one of those topics
that is so polarizing,
depending on what's going on,
where you're from and your,
just your opinions on it.
Like, I've had people close to me
who have been like very critical
of me earning money, doing what I do.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And they they've been
like, well, I do X thing.
Like I do X thing.
That's more contributing to society.
So I don't think it's right.
That, you would get paid more than me.
And that whole argument.
I absolutely despise as well.
- Because it's like,
what can you say to that?
That will get them to understand, right?
- Yeah.
It's like, if you work in like medicine
or something and you firmly believe
that you are doing
something more important,
I would argue, you want
to accept more important
than you are,
but that's just business.
That's how it is.
- That's how it was.
We don't make a virus.
(Joey chuckles)
- I think there are jobs
that are far more important
than the jobs that we have now.
- Absolutely.
- The fact that teachers get paid,
what they do, I think is.
- Fucking atrious.
- Absolutely.
- And I think they should
like get much better pay.
- Yeah.
- But it's also like, you
got to do what you got to do,
make your own bag.
You know what I mean?
Like the world doesn't do
any favors (indistinct).
- That's not something
we can do (indistinct).
- I will advocate for it for change.
And I will do what I can from my position.
But also bro, this economy's right.
(all laughing)
You don't, it's bad, but it's like,
what the that you trooper
can afford a house.
(all laughing)
(indistinct)
where like now being wealthy
as you can afford a house.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
- Like I'm trying to secure my future
because I don't know
how long this job last.
- Exactly.
- Like I've tried to do well while I can,
I would never criticize anyone
who is trying to do what they
need to do to succeed in life.
- Yeah.
- If you're not fucking
over somebody do what you need to do.
Like as long as you're
not actively hurting
or ruining someone's life,
you do what you gotta do to get by
and you do what you need to do, man.
- Yeah.
- I firmly believe that
whatever you want to do,
don't hurt anyone.
Go, for it.
- No, it could be.
'Cause I think one thing
that's one aspect of our job,
which of the,
which we wouldn't have as
like a normal office worker
for example, is job security.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- If you want to get in this field
and you want job security,
I think we have negative job security.
(all laughing)
- Like how hard it is to like,
you apply for like credit cards
or anything long term financing.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] yeah.
- I want to know what your annual income
that is literally impossible
to give a number as a YouTube.
- Yeah.
It's like (indistinct).
- All right.
So I'm not going to be honest with you.
It could be like one K or
it could be 20 K or 100 K.
So basically the whole spectrum of money.
- It's hard to go to a banker and go,
well I think the next
video might do really well.
(all laughing)
I'm thinking maybe like this much.
- It must be like the banks
when they first met YouTubers,
they must have thought they
were like horse gambling.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Yeah.
There were definitely
like money laundering.
(indistinct)
This is like,
this is what we think like
NFTs are now you hunt.
You own.
How much has YouTube?
No, no.
(indistinct) touching that.
- Some money just comes in
(Joey laughs)
when you don't buy or sell anything?
- So it's true?
- What do you, so Sue, who pays you?
I remember the first time,
like having to answer that question,
like when applying for like
our visas and stuff like that,
and I'm having to explain who pays us,
I'm just like, well Google, so.
(Joey laughs)
And so like you set an appointment
for Google you're employee of Google.
You're like.
- [All] No.
(indistinct)
- Yeah.
And then we have this
thing called patriarchy
where people pay us to exist.
- So you are employed to patrons?
Like.
- [All] No.
(all laughing)
- [Connor] Yeah.
- It's like every, every like
red flag is being ticked.
- Yeah.
- Like, when you're a doctor, right?
You, your job is secure.
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
Unless you got around killing people,
you're pretty good.
Like you, it would be
rough not to be employed.
- I just realized how on paper?
Like how similar we must
look to like a drug dealer,
(Joey laughs)
Michaelson laundering money.
If you, go to the checklist,
so you get money put into your account.
- I swear.
When I have to talk to
your accountants, man,
it's the most stressful thing
because that just like I can
see on the zoom calls
the look on their face
while I'm telling them what I'm doing.
(Joey laughs)
Just like, okay.
- I find, it hilarious.
It's the situation of a drug deal,
going to a bank to get along.
(Garnt laughs)
It's like, so do you, so you sell drugs.
Do you work for the pharmacy?
(indistinct)
- Oh, I haven't got the drugs yet.
So this is kind of like collateral.
- Yeah.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- Drug dealers.
What'd you do?
I'm a YouTube.
(all laughing)
- I provide us (indistinct).
- I guess it's a timely topic.
Well, not timely.
I still be like three weeks late,
but that the whole Twitch
thing as well, right?
The earnings.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- People finding out
how much credit is make,
what, was your number, Jerry?
- I don't even.
(indistinct)
- I was like probably 20,000 or something.
I don't know.
- So when you're in top
10,000 ducks, both league.
- Hell yeah, let's go.
- This is why I'm a man of the color.
I am the man.
I am the man of the people I recommend.
I represent the common folk.
(all laughing)
- He's doing God's work right here.
- This man.
(all laughing)
(indistinct)
(Joey laughs)
- I hope, all YouTubes is
get leaked before the next,
(Garnt laughs)
this age is poorly forgotten.
(all laughing)
God that was funny.
It was seeing it.
It was funny seeing the reaction.
'Cause you know, as somebody
who's been doing this.
- Yeah.
- I was not surprised
I've seen these numbers.
- No.
Absolutely not.
- And also I try to tell,
I always try to explain to people,
the reason why let's say
X QC is earning 7 million
and getting all this
absurd amounts of money.
What it seems like absurd is that,
you know that if the
number one person in music
is making billions TV is
making millions, right?
- Yeah.
- The number one at anything
is making tons of models.
- Of course.
- Yeah.
- If you're on the top,
a hundred of something in the world,
you're probably making a lot of money.
- I mean.
- Yeah.
- If someone was bothered to leak it,
you have a suspicion
that it might be a lot of money (laughs).
- And also...
- There's no point leaking something
with the number one
sport is making like 15.
- If for this to exist, right.
For the system to exist
where let's say that creator,
you watch who is making 100 viewers.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Which is all of us at one time.
Right.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- We were all at that one channel.
I distinctly remember
for a year or two, right.
I only got like 40 to 100 views on Twitch,
which I was very happy with.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Absolutely.
- For that person to go,
to make income and
somewhat support themselves
that has to be posted at the top.
Who's proportionally making a lot more,
depending on the audience size, right?
- [Garnt] Of course.
- It's a system that works.
Is it, super fair that
some people make fucking
100s of millions?
(laughs) It's up to you.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I mean, what I will say is that those,
from what I saw,
there is a lot more money on YouTube
as opposed to Twitch what it seems.
- So the amount of work you do as well,
especially.
- Yeah.
I mean the YouTube,
like the top 100 YouTube
as a party making a lot more than
the top 100 Twitch streamers.
- [Joey] I think so.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- From what I understand.
- [Joey] yeah.
- How it works.
- I think so as well.
- (indistinct) Mr. Beach,
there's no risk to beast on Twitch
(all laughing)
(indistinct)
and all the ones that are
on Twitch that involve money
in gambling are extremely sketchy.
- Yeah.
- Very, very sketchy.
- Definitely.
- And that's a whole nother thing.
The whole gambling side of Twitch is.
- Yeah.
That's a (indistinct).
- I mean, you should have
inherently is a massive platform,
much bigger than Twitter.
- It is much bigger than Twitch.
- Like some of these channels
that are uploading, I,
God knows how much Dom man's making.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I'm sure he makes
(indistinct) revenue in one day.
(clears throat)
- Yeah.
- It was from sponsors, right?
Like it's totally crazy and we,
I am still shocked that people
are like top influencers earn
how much, when there are some of them
that are going around in private jets,
Lamborghinis, all this stuff.
Right.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's you know, I wish I
was I've wished that was me.
- I mean (indistinct).
- I'd love to buy my whole, all of Wales,
(Garnt laughs)
the GDP of Wales.
I'd love to reinvigorate the economy.
- I mean,
I'll be surprised how much
Hollywood movie actors make
or how much, some of the
top music artists make?
(indistinct)
Yeah.
And then like, and then like,
this is like a new entertainment platform.
Of course, top creators are
going to be making millions.
You know, we're not at
the billion stage yet
because we're not as big
as the other end statement industries,
but these are what the
top creators are making.
And that's just,
we are just like a baby mode
of the entertainment industry,
of like the rest of the end establishing
the industry (indistinct).
- I'm sure when like massive
Hollywood actors with posts,
starting to make these
like massive loads of money
and that got found out,
I'm sure the general
public was like, wait,
these actors make how much money.
- Maybe, maybe.
- Exactly.
I feel the exact same thing.
It's like, it's such a new thing now.
And it's also just so unprecedented
because it's so different to anything
that you see on like TV or
radio or anything like that.
- This just three guys trying
to justify their income,
the conversation.
(all laughing)
- And I'm like, what?
The Twitch thing.
It's like it's most of it's public anyway.
- Yeah.
That, was what it was especially with,
which thing is that most content creators,
sub account is public and this income
was somewhat known or close to now.
- Right.
- yeah.
- You could easily have
like kind of guessed
you would have been.
Right.
So it's like quite odd.
- Why is it a surprise?
- I think that people that
I think a lot of content creditors
were like a couple of people
are still surprised about it.
I think the people that were surprised
about it were people
who weren't involved in Twitch
or weren't touching it at all.
- Yeah.
- And so we were being like,
I'm going to be a Twitch stream.
I'm like, yeah.
Good luck.
(all laughing)
That, is harder than YouTube.
- Yeah.
- Twitch is hard.
Right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- And it's, the search algorithms
aren't nearly as optimized
as YouTube or TikTok or something.
- Well, I mean, it's, it just shows that,
there is, this is a
growing industry right now.
Like this is,
it's weird seeing how YouTube
and Twitch have evolved
as time has gone on and seeing it go grow.
I think that's where the different lies
and where they get their perspective from,
which was the difference
between say Twitch,
streamers and YouTubers
versus Hollywood celebrities
or big music artists is that, we,
a lot of us started off in
that exact same position
as everyone else, it is
an equal playing field.
So we don't get,
we didn't have to go
through these auditions or,
go get signed by this massive music label
or anything like that.
We grew organically buyers by ourselves.
- Yeah.
- [Connor} Yeah.
- I think it's just the shock that someone
who went through that avenue
is able to earn that much.
- True.
- Right.
- But it's, also like,
I think what a lot of people
don't like to give credit
to is that a lot of creators
who are earning that much now, right.
At some point or another,
they were where they were
working full-time hours
on top of whatever else
they were doing on something
that wasn't paying them.
- Yeah.
But that's the things.
- For years.
- Yeah.
I feel like Twitch stream is again,
is like a lot like YouTube as well.
Like the biggest difference is
that I think a lot of people
see them more as like this person
that's on the same level
where I was like a little more portable.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- It's just like the dude
across the road type of guy.
Whereas like, no one views.
(indistinct)
- Bone, a billion dollars,
and people would be like,
"Oh Connor."
- That's just Connor being Connor.
(Connor laughs)
- With that, it'd be like, oh my God,
it's just different.
Right.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Then there's this
weird kind of dichotomy
of how they expect
the standards of traditional celebrities
to influences and stuff.
And I've got,
was going to say it was
because something else got
you put up a second salary.
I'm fucking dumb.
(Garnt laughs)
- Wait, what?
- I was going to say
something after Joey's point.
And I totally forgot it.
- What was Joey's point again.
- My point was that Twitch stream
is on YouTube as a scene
a lot more as like,
just like a friend, like,
one more possible, not
this person in the clouds,
like a little like
Hollywood act as though.
- 'Cause you know,
when you first start making
money on YouTube, it's exciting.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] yeah.
- Right?
YouTube is on my car.
I 100 bucks.
It crazy.
- Yeah.
- It's insane.
And then you're really
proud because you're like,
"Oh my God,
I can get paid for doing
this thing that I love."
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And then for the first two years
I was making enough
to maybe buy myself a movie ticket $10,000
(all laughing)
the first year, I think I
only made like $500 from it.
- Yeah.
- Second year, probably like $5,000.
Still not enough to live off,
but I was like, whoa,
it looks like exciting.
All right.
And then it goes off and it scales up
and that's when I think
you start to feel bad
about how much money you're making.
Right.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Do you ever get like
imposter syndrome about it?
- Of course.
(indistinct)
- I think most YouTubes.
- Yeah.
- Get imposter syndrome.
- The reason why a lot of
YouTubers don't want to talk about
that money is because
a lot of them feel bad.
- [Joey] Yeah.
(Connor chuckles)
- I think, I don't
think they should write.
I wish we lived in a system
where no one gave a about money
and people could just
be more honest about it
and that people could
'cause then I think that would make us.
- Which thing came out because now.
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah.
- People like wearing the
earnings with, on their badge.
- Well, 'cause I think that it makes
a better atmosphere for everyone
to be able to negotiate for
better like pay in their job.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- You know, there's
like in traditional jobs
there's sometimes even
though they're not allowed
to ask you to do this,
that the bosses will be like,
don't talk about how
much money you're making,
but you're allowed to,
but people don't
because they're scared
and they don't want...
- They don't wanna be judged.
- But if you're doing the exact same thing
as your colleague,
whether it be on Twitch
or on the same job,
you should be able to argue
that you should be valued
the same way they are.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And it's one of those things where,
when I meet other content
creators in private,
I'll ask them like,
how much did you get for
the sponsorship deal?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I'll be like, what'd you get?
'Cause I want to make sure
you didn't get over because I know
how much it should we get it.
- Because like speaking
from people in the people in industry,
nobody teaches each other.
And one of the stupidest things
that a lot of content creators,
don't talk to each other about this,
even though the more content
creators you talk to,
the more you realize, oh,
a lot of people are getting fucked.
- Yeah.
- Because they've never talked
to any other content
creator about this right?
- Yeah.
- Tight taking deals
that like, for example,
like I took a deal for
a sponsor on a video.
This is when I was getting
around about an average 50,000
to 100,000 views.
I took a sponsorship for $100.
- What?
- And the video got half a million views.
That's not, worth it by
the way, something a video.
Let's say when you're about,
if you have 50,000 to
100,000 average views,
you should probably be getting a ball
about maybe 2000 to $4,000.
- It's 20 to 50 times, 2000 (indistinct).
- Which sounds like a lot.
I know that sounds like
a lot to a lot of people,
but this is advertising space, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- This is eyeballs that you're getting.
So you have to think of it like that.
So you can naturally.
- I guess that's where our
knowledge comes in (indistinct).
Right?
- Where it's, not like
that's not a set number
because it all depends on the client.
- Yeah.
- It all depends on the
product you're promoting.
Some clients in certain spaces
are willing to sell you like
this spot for a higher price.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Some aren't it's.
(indistinct)
Yeah.
It's really comes down to experience.
But if you're a content creator,
you should really be talking
to other content creators.
If you have no idea
what to charge a client.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
- If you have no idea,
then I've I've liked.
'Cause here's the thing I've searched up.
I've searched up like before,
like YouTube of like
how much you should be
charging certain clients.
And unlike all the YouTubers I've seen,
who have said how much you
should be charging have got the,
I've got the number wrong.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And that's because a lot of them
aren't big creators, you know?
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah.
- And like the numbers,
really depend on where you are on YouTube
and it really comes down to experience.
And what your other,
what other people are
doing in your fields,
which really depends on
how much you can charge.
Right.
- Yeah.
- So I feel like talking
to you guys about it
before we are now able to charge more
because we realized that we
all get charged different prices.
For certain...
- Mean, it's also not just about like
the sub count and like view
counts, stuff like that.
So I feel a lot of it,
especially nowadays that like
companies are looking for
forwards, like branding Powell.
- Yeah.
- Like you could have the two channels
could have the exact same
number of sobs and views,
but one could be a stronger brand
and that in and of itself.
Right?
Yeah.
And it depends on like the
audience and the demographics.
So there's so many
components that go into it.
It's not just like a bare bones.
Like I get this many views on average,
therefore I should be
getting this amount of money.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Like it's completely
case-by-case and lunch.
- Which is like, my
general advice to anyone
who is independent and not even
a YouTube, but an artist, right.
We've had to learn what our value is.
That's the biggest thing.
- Oh yeah.
- You have to, like, you have
to know what your value is.
- Not be ashamed to say it.
- And not be ashamed to say it.
- Whether they ask how much it costs.
(Connor chuckles)
- - When it comes to
negotiations with a company
or with a fellow client,
you can't be ashamed to big up your value
because you are bringing
something for them.
Right?
You are, bringing something to the table
and you need to articles about it.
- Nothing hurts me more
than seeing an artist
on the selling themselves.
- So much.
It hurts so much.
(indistinct)
- Like, I always make sure, like,
if I'm working with an artist,
I'm like, you sure you want that?
Like, I can give you more.
I think you're worth a
little bit more than that.
You, gotta have a little bit
of confidence in yourself,
but you can't be scared to like,
obviously you can't like ask
for an egregious amount at,
at a small price, but you know,
there is a limit that you can go.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And it's okay to step over
that limit even slightly just
to get your name out there.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- If you really believe in your work,
but yeah, just, oh my God,
I've seen so many artists just be like,
yeah, I'll give you like this amount.
And it's like a 10th of what
I was envisioning is like,
I don't know if you want to
do that (laughs) to like,
be a little more confident in yourself.
You know.
- This episode is sponsored by honey.
- We all shop online
and we've all seen that promo code field
towards us at the checkout.
But thanks to honey manually searching
for coupon codes is a thing of the past.
- [Connor] It's funny as
the free browser extension
to the scouting instead promo codes
and applies the best one.
It finds your card, honey sports,
over 30,000 online stores.
They read from sites
from tech Damie products
to popular fashion brands
and even food delivery.
- All right.
Picture this in your head,
ladies and gentlemen,
I'm going to paint a mental
image for you right now.
Imagine you're shopping on
one of your favorite sites.
- I see.
- Okay.
When you're at the checkout,
the honey button drops
down and all you have to do
is click apply coupons.
- Oh my God.
- You wait a few seconds.
And honey searches for coupons.
You can find for that site.
And if honey finds a working coupon,
you'll just watch the prices.
Look at the prices dropping.
Now.
(indistinct)
- I can only get so erect.
- Joey.
I have a question (indistinct).
- As you know,
I've been reading recently
and I've just saved $20
on new kitchen equipment.
- Well, my new house honey
has found it's over 17 million members
over $2 billion in savings.
And if you don't already have one
or you can be straight up
missing out on free savings,
it's literally free and
installs in a few seconds.
And by getting it,
you'll be doing yourself
a solid and supporting this podcast.
So get honey for free@joinedhoney.com
slash trash tastes.
That's joinhoney.com/trash tastes.
- The episode.
(clears throat)
- And then I think another thing
that a lot of people don't talk about
when it comes to like
the economics of YouTube
and like getting,
getting paid for this as a job
is that is the amount of time
a lot of content creators will go
before they get big doing work
and not getting paid and
not doing this for money.
I mean, I did YouTube for like seven,
eight years before I
saw my first paycheck.
Right.
And especially in, especially
nowadays, it's a super,
super competitive industry in a super,
super competitive field.
So my like whenever someone
comes to me and ask me
for advice about how to
make YouTube a job, I,
the first thing I ask them is,
do you have the time to
take a year off in your
life without getting paid
and working at night,
like working harder
than a nine to five job
because that's like,
that's the minimum sacrifice
you will have to do nowadays too,
unless you're like super,
super lucky to do YouTube.
And even if you do that,
you might not even get popular.
You might, it might not
even come to fruition.
So are you willing attempt to
make that sacrifice in your
life for a chance to have this as a job,
which is why, like,
I feel very lucky to have this position.
- Yeah.
Likewise.
- But you know, I did.
I do, you know, I do know that I,
there was some portion of
luck within my career path,
but also everyone I've met,
including all three of us
worked super hard as well.
We went through a point
where we were working harder
than the nine to five job
without getting paid or being paid like
less than minimum wage
to get where we are.
And we did that for about a year.
And I feel like,
I feel like a lot of
people who are maybe older
who are more established to be like,
I got a nine to five job.
I can't really take a year out in my life.
That's why a lot of YouTubers,
you see a start off in like
college or in high school
when you do have that time.
And all I can say to that is I'm,
you know, I'm sorry.
That's just the way it works.
- Yeah.
- You can't like,
it's not a company, YouTube.
Isn't like YouTube.
You're not a paid salary, man.
You know?
It's.
- Yeah.
I mean, like, as an example,
it's like, you know, like Mr. Bass,
like Jimmy was barely got
any views for like the first,
like six, seven years of his career.
- Yeah.
- And then all of a sudden
he's he's at where he's at now.
Right?
But like,
I think what a lot of people forget
is that he didn't just
come out of nowhere.
He didn't just make a
video and it immediately,
get them 50 million solves.
Right?
It's like he worked for that shit.
- It takes a very long time.
- Yeah.
- And that's the thing that
everyone wants to gloss over.
And that's not me just trying
to justify why people should
make 50 million dollars a year,
but it's just, you should,
you can't criticize it without
first understanding that
and appreciating that it does
sometimes take a ton of work.
And the one thing that people love
to forget is that life is not fair.
(Garnt laughs)
(indistinct)
- Right now.
- Could, you could put just as many hours,
if not more hours into
playing guitar or something
and nothing could come of it.
I always.
- Think of the 100s and 1000s
of guitars (indistinct).
- Right.
It's like, you also have to, like,
I think one thing that is kind
of oversold in life is that
if you put X of hours into something,
it'll just work out.
- Yeah.
- And it's not always that simple.
- You know if you're
getting into something
that is extremely popular worldwide.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's going to be way
harder than if you're,
for example, making anime videos
on a website called YouTube in 2015.
- [Joey] Yeah.
(Connor chuckles)
- [Garnt] I mean...
- I it's differences in scale
of what you're trying to compete.
You know, I'm sure everyone
on will everyone in the world started
doing the type of content
that we were doing.
I think we'd be out of a job pretty soon.
'Cause no doubt.
There'll be other people
who are better than us that would
happen, but that's not,
but not everybody's doing it.
- Yeah.
- I feel that's why it's called
a dream job for or a reason.
Right?
- I mean like I did take a massive risk
with my career choices,
because back then when
I had a steady paid job,
I had a career path I
could pursue and I liked.
- Where did you work a gain.
- I worked at the BBC.
Did she know that?
- She.
(Garnt laughs)
- And to bring it back.
- And the timestamps
it'd be like justifying
or privileges (all laughing)
this a section of the.
- No, because yeah,
I did sacrifice that a proven career path
for an industry
that was not proven that an industry
that didn't exist back then, that I,
that wasn't proven where I could do this
more than a year or two.
And I took a risk that it was going
to turn out to something.
And I was lucky enough
that it did turn out.
You know, nowadays it's
a different ball game.
You know, I took that
risk with my career path.
If you want to be a
YouTube or Twitch streamer,
you have to take a different risk.
And it's a different risk,
but the risk to reward is like
the rewards are there to be seen.
And that's why people will
take risks to get that reward.
- The one lucky thing
about YouTube and twitches
that you can do in your downtime,
you can put a little bit
of effort here and there,
see some results,
see that there's a demand for it
and then dedicate more time to it.
That is one good thing about it.
Like, you know, yes,
you're going to be at a disadvantage.
If you are working like God
said, and you are 30 plus,
and you've got a life
that you need to maintain.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But it's not impossible.
Like there is,
there are some ways there are cases
where it has worked out again.
- Yeah.
- It's just harder and the
playing field isn't level,
but it never is.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You know, I'm sure that
if you let's say you just had a friend
who was a big YouTube,
you're already at a massive advantage
because they can help you out.
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- Or you have a family history
of using cameras or editing,
like there's all kinds of
variations of advantages,
but that's life.
I feel that can apply with any job,
anything in life (laughs).
- Yeah.
I think I can play with any job right?
- (indistinct), but I guess
because we're somewhat public figures,
so it's a lot more.
- I would say every career
path has their own obstacles.
- Of course.
- Especially like, for example,
if I will take engineering, for example,
it's actually not advantageous
to you to do like,
to do a good job in your company
and stay in that company.
Because like the raises
you get are better.
If you move companies
and you're constantly moving companies.
- True.
- Right.
And that, I don't think
that should be right,
because I think you should be.
I think every employee should be rewarded
for doing a good job at that company.
But the sad reality of it is,
is that a lot of the times
in a lot of career paths,
you can get a much better
raised by changing companies.
And then moving back to
the original company.
And you're thinking
like, why can't I just,
why can't the original company just see me
for my worth to begin with?
It's like Twitch stream
is moving to YouTube.
(all laughing)
- That's true.
(indistinct)
(all laughing)
All right.
It's free privileged individuals,
the fiber, you know what?
The one thing, the one
comment that I actually,
I know I'm just,
I'm inviting this comment
now you've changed.
(all laughing)
- I like the old blank better.
- And it's like, are you
saying that I should,
I would be the same person
I am at 20 years old
that I am now because you're insane.
How about if you think that
I should be the same post
I post, I'm gonna change.
If I didn't do YouTube,
I would still change.
(Joey laughs)
It would change regardless.
I'm becoming more miserable.
(indistinct), you change.
Right.
- Yeah.
- And when people comment saying like,
oh, they've changed.
You know, they're different from them.
Like, yes, of course, as you should,
you should become more
confident as you get older.
- I wouldn't be worried.
I wouldn't be worried
if you didn't change.
- Right.
You should mature.
You should change your opinion.
You should act differently.
That's called life.
If you're not doing that,
what are you doing?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- What are you, why aren't you changing?
Why aren't you improving yourself?
And...
- Exactly.
- I, but then I guess that's.
- That's the thing.
- It's proving.
(indistinct)
Becoming more gluttonous, more wealthy.
- Yeah.
- He's changed since he
got his Audi Ben he's got.
(indistinct)
(all laughing)
- Spending money on drip now
instead of going to primer,
how dare he.
(all laughing)
- It all changed when Connor
got this pumpkin spice latte,
Starbucks for the first time.
(all laughing)
you have change.
- That one trip to Los
Angeles changed everything.
- I changed my mind.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
I'm not going to be broke anymore.
(all laughinga)
- No, but I mean, I agree you should,
or you should always be changing.
You know, I think there is a difference
between changing and,
becoming a bit snobby a bit.
- Yeah.
- Because you know, like
I still can't stand.
What can I say?
I still can't stand flex culture.
- Yeah.
Well, it's weird, isn't it?
Because you want to be able to celebrate
and support the people who
have really worked hard
and have done great stuff.
And I've made some good
content and, and you know, I,
I want to see them do well,
but then I guess there's a very fine line,
especially for audiences.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- What is considered
flexing and then what is,
I'm not going to go
around and be like, oh,
this is what I bought and I'm killing it.
You know, all my
investments are doing well.
(all laughing)
- Well, he's just like
full on a video being like,
so here's how my stocks doing this month.
(all laughing)
- It's a doge coin.
As you can see.
- I got into stocks when
everyone got into stocks
in the red for a very long time.
(all laughing)
So there's no flexing for me.
And.
- But it is a fine line between like,
what is flexing
and what is just being proud
of your accomplishments.
All right.
- Yeah.
- It's like, what is the,
how, when does it change.
- Ah, it's hard, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- Because you don't want to
be like, yeah, I'm doing well.
But you also,
'cause some people perceive
that as you've changed.
- Right.
So it's like,
what do you do not want me to like
show you my achievements or.
- Okay.
So people will,
people support small craters
and then they also turn on them
when they're,
when they find out they're
doing well sometimes.
- Yeah.
It's the underground
band going three years.
- Yeah.
- Just in a different field,
they've changed everything
ever since they were successfully
signed by the music label,
(Joey laughs)
don't like their music anymore
talking about different things.
I liked them before they
became an animator of mini.
- And I don't get annoyed
if someone prefers all the content
of mine or they prefer
because the style has changed.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Right.
And I understand that when
you change your style,
not every style is for everyone.
And I don't get annoyed
and people are like,
I prefer the old videos.
I'm like, all right,
that's fair enough.
I get it.
- Like, it's your taste.
All right.
Yeah.
- But I'm not going to change it.
'Cause that's not what I want to do.
- Yeah.
I mean, I still get comments
that are still like,
I miss the anime zone.
Well, when are you going to bring back
the anime zone reviews?
And I'm just like, dude,
I killed off reviews for like a reason.
Okay.
Yes.
I have changed in that sense.
I'm not doing enemies.
I'm not doing enemies
zone reviews anymore.
- And people still ask
me for my let's play.
I'm like.
- But then I also get
annoyed at content creators
that like wine at that audience,
all the time, they're like, oh,
why are you complaining?
You don't let the new videos.
It's like, well,
you need to go out your way
and make something it's different.
You can't expect your
audience to just follow suit.
And like, it's up to you.
- Sometimes you just have to be like,
just screw up the audience things.
If this is what makes you happy.
You do that content?
- I hate YouTube.
Is that sit there and make videos,
whining that they're not doing well.
I'm like, go over it.
It's you, if you change
something or you're doing,
you're not making like
stuff that is keeping up
with the times that's on you.
I believe.
- Yeah.
That, is part of the job
that you signed up for.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
- You should know this, you know.
- And if you're a doctor,
you have to keep learning
the new medical practices.
You can't, go doing shit (Joey laughs)
like the 1960s.
- Oh you a COVID here's some leeches.
- You can't do that.
There's differences.
There's regulations and you're
forced to do it, but God.
Imagine if there wasn't
people would never update their thing.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And then a reason why they do it
is because it's to the detriment
of anyone else around us.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- The problem is with YouTube,
it's not to the detriment of anyone else.
If a content creator falls off,
there are tons more,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah I know.
- It is up to you to make sure
that you are making stuff.
- You are up to date.
- When my channel falls off,
there can be plenty of curb,
your enthusiasm memes
of this section of the podcast, you know?
- Yeah.
- And I'll, you know, it's,
if I stop trying to change, that's on me.
If I don't want to do that anymore.
I understand that.
- Favorite comments I get though, is like,
it's not even the you've changed all the,
I liked the old content better.
It's the youthful and off.
- Yeah.
- You're irrelevant
- You're irrelevant now.
And I'm like, what?
Because you Postly,
don't like myself now
I'm suddenly irrelevant
in the grand scheme of things.
It's like.
- Yeah.
I mean, yeah.
There's people who are not
going to like what (indistinct).
- And that's fine.
I'm going to try to appeal to everybody.
Like if you don't like
it, that's cool, dude.
There are literally
thousands of content crazy.
You could go and watch.
- Yeah.
It's not strange.
It's strange.
I don't really know.
What's your opinion gone.
Tell me your opinion.
- My opinion on changing.
(all laughing)
- The.
You want to opinion on trash tastes.
(indistinct)
(all laughing)
I don't know.
- No.
I mean like for me, like changing
is part of our job.
- Yeah.
And life, I think you
should change as a push it.
- [Joey] Yeah, absolutely.
- When I go back and see
my friends from school,
if they're exactly the same
as they were in school,
I'm like...
- That's a red flag.
- Why?
- Yeah.
- But some people don't change.
Did you notice that?
- I did.
And I don't give a if they
haven't that's on them.
It's I think it's like, oh, that's odd.
Like nothing has changed
your point of view
in life in five years.
Like nothing has made you think different.
Not none of your experiences
have changed who you are.
Okay.
Fair enough.
But then I don't want them to be like, oh,
you've changed.
It's like.
- Yes, I have.
- Get over it (chuckles).
- Well, you, of course I've changed.
I moved to a foreign country
and I have no idea what's
going on off the time.
And I barely know how to
communicate with my taxi driver.
I've changed.
- Yeah.
- I'm fighting for my life, man (laughs).
Exactly.
- No, because I feel like
that just says a lot of
us about us as people,
because I'm constantly looking for change.
I'm like.
- Same.
- I'm like uncomfortable
when things stay the same for too long.
And I think that's why I.
- Get scared when start to get not right.
- Which is kind of makes
YouTube my perfect job,
because I never want to stay still.
I'm constantly wanting to change.
- I like my boss.
- Not just like being in Korea,
but in like my own life.
Like I, that's why I've moved
countries so many times.
I still don't know why I
want to settle down yet
because I'm like scared
to like stay in one place for too long.
You know?
I just like, do you know,
that's just me as a person.
- Yeah.
- I constantly like changing my life.
And I'm not saying
if you are the type of person
who doesn't change and stays
comfortable in one place,
there's nothing inherently
wrong with them.
But all I ask is you don't
judge us for changing.
- For changing (laughs).
- Changing as well.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And you know,
there are some people in some people
who I was mates with back in the day
that I have less than common with now.
And that's just part
of me having to accept
that I have changed and we
have less in common with.
(indistinct)
- We're going to push
our values on you guys.
So, you know, just don't (indistinct).
(Garnt laughs)
- [Connor] Sure.
- Except for drip by drip.
You should buy drip.
(all laughing)
- But I'll give my opinion.
You don't have to take it.
- Absolutely.
- I'm on very Brashard lipid.
And I know that, yeah.
- I'm not going to cry over you.
Not agreeing with me.
(Joey laughs)
- I could get annoyed at people.
Completely misinterpret what I'm saying.
That doesn't sound like,
how did the did you get that?
Like.
- You're standing in a completely
different argument that.
- I need a toilet quickly
go pitch yourself.
- Speaking of going to your hometown
and see if people have changed.
Right.
I do have a funny story about someone
who I met in my university town
that has definitely changed in a way
that I didn't imagine.
- Okay.
So what happened is I
went to see someone mates
who are living in Bristol right now,
which was by my city where
I went to university.
I went to university of Bristol.
And so we were at this club, right?
And we meet, a guy there and this guy who
I wasn't very close to him in university,
but a word on the street was
he was the type of guy who,
if you needed certain substances,
that was the guy to call.
Right.
Okay.
And so, I'm just having a casual chat
and he asked me what I'm doing.
And I was like, oh, I
start talking about Japan.
I saw it, start talking
about being a YouTuber,
living in Japan and stuff like that.
And he goes, "Oh, I do
something about Japan now."
And I'm like, what the do you do now?
What, is this person?
So like to, to preface,
this is a guy who applied
to love islands once.
Right?
(Joey laughs)
He's not the kind of guy
who I would expect has any interest
in a male in Japan at all.
Right.
- Yeah.
- And he goes, oh yeah.
Like, I deal in ideal Pokemon cards.
Now.
I was like, off.
What, is this?
And he's like,
I'm like, how are you
getting Pokemon cards?
I was like, oh, I love Pokemon.
I've always loved it.
And I was like,
how are we getting Pokemon cards?
And I'm like, God,
I've got contacts.
And I'm just like,
why did you have to
make it sound like that?
(all laughing)
So, and so he takes me,
he takes me over to one side.
Right.
He's just like, "Yo, gone,
gone, come here, come here.
Look, I've got a good deal.
If you're interested in Pokemon go."
(Joey laughs)
I was just like, whoa.
I was like, you're
taking the (indistinct).
You're taking the.
I was like me.
I just sent off.
I just sent off a shiny MuTu.
He got graded nine grade nine,
shiny new to make first edition.
You can be yours.
I'm sending it,
but I'll give you a good deal.
I'll give you a good deal.
And I'm just like,
this is the weirdest offshoot
of breaking bad I've ever seen.
- We've got great.
(all laughing)
- And so, yeah, like,
so this guy went through
a complete career change apparently.
And is now as in, is
now dealing poker one.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Got contacts and came free
to pause out a bunch of businesses.
(indistinct)
- That's the whole weirdest aspect
of this whole Pokemon card
was it was that people were sending cards,
they're cards for Logan Paul to open.
- Why?
- So that they could be in the video.
- Some kind of like modern
cooking that I'm not aware of,
where like you don't get in trouble
without opening your own things now.
Or you have to send them to someone
else who can open them,
but better.
(Connor chuckles)
It's like a politician.
It's like a full of,
oh, he's opening that Pokemon cup.
(indistinct)
like, what is this?
We can walk we're gear.
Are we in where we don't get enjoyment?
It's like, it's like, well,
I've gone buy a bunch of Gacha
and I make Joey login
my account and do it.
'Cause he does it.
- I mean that also is a thing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Man] Garnt always pulls
for me and I kinda get it.
(Garnt laughs)
(indistinct)
- Modern.
Cocking is this like,
this is, what is this one?
When did this begin?
- I'm pretty sure.
There's like a bunch of
like ginching YouTubers
who gave they get like take
like poles for other players.
It's like.
- I feel like it's just
like living vicariously.
So then just one person.
Right?
Because-
- I guess.
- With Pokemon cards,
it feels like a weird extra step
where you would send these
like extremely valuable cards
to be open to that.
Do they ever come back to the post?
- Yeah.
They come back to the person.
(Joey laughs)
- I think it's, I think I kind of get it.
'Cause it's kinda like
sharing your, like, like,
like this it's all about
the experience, right?
Because you're, sharing the experience
with say your favorite content creator
because you know, there's a difference,
you know, there is a
difference doing it yourself.
Unlike having to freak out by yourself
and like doing it as like a group.
I was like, okay.
- Kind of makes sense.
I guess it just feels like
this weird kind of year.
Are we in a bit of an extra,
some people just don't
want to open up their own
things anymore.
I'm going to invite gone over
to open up my Dyson vacuum
just so I can get the true experience
of how a dog should take off appeals.
A Dyson should be on box.
God will do it better than me.
Isn't it weird?
Like, okay.
I understand.
There's a shared
experience, but it's weird.
Yeah.
It's strange.
Right?
- It's strange.
- It's a bit strange.
- I don't think it's strange.
I would you.
- Do it?
- Would you send off your
cards for someone else?
- No, but I would, if I'm like,
say opening, like a rare pack,
I'd want my boys in there. I'd be like,
I wouldn't want to do it by myself.
(Joey laughs)
- I want to like share the experience.
- Boys.
5:00 PM.
I'm opening up.
- The fresh pack right here.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Non crinkled cards.
- Look it's,
it's just like part of the fun
is the shared experience of
just doing this exciting thing, you know?
- But when does it not become your thing?
It's not your thing anymore.
It's someone else's.
- Yeah.
- What'd you mean.
- If you send your cards off to load
and Paul to open up.
- Do they, does he send them back?
- Yeah.
- No, no.
But it was a massive difference.
- It's like you being cut out, right?
- Yeah.
There's a massive difference
between like you gathering
your friends to do
it in front of your friends
and then sending your cards to
someone that you don't know.
- Who maybe (indistinct).
- And they don't know you.
- Thanks (indistinct), thanks
for giving me the call.
- Yeah.
- That's it.
- I mean, it's that with extra steps,
but like you're sharing
that with like say one
of the biggest content
creators on the platform.
So it's like, Joey chose
to do this role for me,
Joey is that like.
- The problem is like majority of like,
if they're like streaming on Twitch,
the majority of the chat
isn't going to be like, oh,
this is the card that
was sent by this person.
Holy.
- I guess I kind of get it
now that you say it like that.
I do kind of understand that
you could get more enjoyment.
I've seen other people
react to your thing.
- Yeah.
- But it is your strange,
what level of consumerism
are we on right now?
(Joey laughs)
We buy things for ourselves,
for someone else to open.
For what level is this of Capitalism?
Is this is what they're going to use.
Unlike other communist, look at it.
They don't even buy
their own stuff anymore.
They buy it for someone else to open it.
(Garnt laughs)
It's like, okay, I kind of get it now,
but it is strange.
- Yeah.
- It's a bit weird.
- You have to admit objectively.
It sounds bizarre.
- I mean, you can make
anything sound weird
if you like put it in the-
- Try it, try it, do it.
(all laughing)
Right.
I'll give you an example.
(all laughing)
- But like, I mean like that's kinda like
the same kind of argument when let's play
as thoughts to be, get popular, right?
Like it's a bit weird, you know?
I mean, you kind of just
watching someone play
a video game and not
even good at the video.
- Well, okay.
I would argue with that one though.
It's not like I'm buying a
physical copy of the game.
- Yeah is sending it to (indistinct) plan.
- I'm not, I don't have a copy anymore.
And then I'll watch you play it.
- I'm sending it again to the left lane.
And then they're like,
just after you finish it,
just give me back the game.
- Again, people do buy games, streamers,
but then they normally do
that because they want to get,
they want to see them have
the experience that they had.
So.
- It's, all about the shared experience.
Right?
- I guess I do understand the feeling.
It's just,
it does seem strange to me
that this even was a thought
that someone was like,
I'm going to send my cards to Logan Paul.
(Joey laughs)
- It's like, is the way
you've seen the sentence.
- It's a kin to like
being cocked in my mind.
(all laughing)
- It's like I say, my girlfriend
- I won't get as much
satisfaction out of doing this.
I would watching someone else do this.
- It is kind of more satisfied.
Right?
I mean, I take
(all laughing)
(indistinct)
- (indistinct) That's cool, dude.
- No, I mean, like for example,
with Gacha it is like a lot
more fun to pull on street.
- Comes back to Gacha.
- It does always come
back to catch a ride,
but I mean.
- That's kind of peak entertainment, 2021.
- I mean, that's what
Pokemon cards are, right.
- Yeah.
It's.
- Just physical.
Gacha right.
(indistinct)
So it's a lot funner
to do with your mates.
Like every time I remember
when we were like addicted
to art legs, every time,
every time Joey was in
the office, he was like,
I'm going to do a pool.
And we're like, oh,
let's see what he gets.
And it's a lot more fun to do with mates
because if you don't get it,
then your mates will be
like, ha you're a idiot.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Right, right.
But it's like your buying
packs for Joey to Paul because.
- He got the cards back.
So.
- Let's say, yeah, yeah, I guess you do.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
But I guess like the
equivalent of that is like,
I'm gonna give you 100 bucks
to pull on dark nights.
But once you finished the polls,
I need you to send me the 100 bucks back.
(Joey chuckles)
I like, that's a little weird.
- I mean, it's more like
you're just giving the
phone to another person,
Joey, you do the pool
for me trust (indistinct)
- Giving your significant others
or someone else for one evening.
Magical love, nature that you can view.
(Garnt laughs)
- While you sit back and enjoy the show.
- I'm not crazy right.
With this comparison I.
- Get where you're coming from.
Yeah.
But it's just, now that I think about it,
it is not as weird (laughs)
as I initially thought.
- Okay.
- That's weird.
Is that weird that we
don't find that weird?
- Let me, you let me
sell you another idea.
- Okay.
So, like you watch movies
and enemies and stuff like that.
Right?
Right.
So, that.
Like imagine instead of
watching a two hour movie,
you could watch three
blokes sitting on a set,
arguing about chicken
breasts and chicken thighs.
How's that sound?
- I was like quality context.
(Garnt laughs)
I have one question.
Why subscribe?
- Yeah.
- I sign up.
- I suppose.
What would you categorize?
Why'd you think?
Why do you think trash
taste is successful?
(Garnt laughs)
- (indistinct) is a sucking our own Dick.
(indistinct).
- So good.
Can you explain?
- Why do you think, what is,
why would someone go and watch us
instead of watching a movie,
which objectively better entertainment.
- I could give,
like a really deep answer
now that is just like,
I feel like...
- I'm ready for the truth bond.
- I feel like we've,
the whole shared experience
thing we've talking about.
A lot of people would
now crave kind of like
that feeling of like a relationship
or like a closeness of someone and people.
A lot of people can feel
that parasocial eat by,
for example, sending their,
their cards to their favorite streamers
or sending some money
for their favorite
Gacha streamers to pool,
or just watching three blokes,
three friends talk for two hours.
You know, you get that feeling
that you're connected with someone,
you, they, you have that
feeling of connection,
even though that connection
isn't technically real.
You know, and I feel like
a lot of content nowadays,
especially with the younger generation
is gut like a lot of the most,
successful streamers and a lot of the most
successful content creators are people
who can accurately represent
that feeling of a close connection,
a parasocial relationship I'd say, see it.
That was, my deep answer.
- I'm 14.
And this is deep, bro.
(Garnt chuckles)
- My, meme answer is just,
it's just three blocks shine ship.
(all laughing)
- I guess.
'Cause we died,
we didn't strive to have that.
Right.
We just make, we just talk,
(Connor laughs)
but it's always much deeper.
- (indistinct) self satisfaction.
- We just wanted to make it
show we just chat shakes.
- I mean, we didn't try for that.
It just happened by (indistinct).
- Complete luck.
So like, I guess the whole,
I watched a video by what's his name?
Glinka is it whose name
did it be about only fans
and the more, not the sexual side,
but more so the power of social side
where a lot of guys are on there
because they that's like
the closest they feel
that they can get to your girlfriend.
- Yeah.
- And that was really
sad watching that video
because you had interviews with people
who are only fans subscribers know,
and as much as we meme on only fans.
And then to know that,
that whole thing about,
earlier we mentioned the whole density,
we're going to take jokes.
I do feel very sorry for these guys.
Like a lot of them that feel
that they have no other choice
or there is no other choice for them.
- Yeah.
- Just life circumstances or
maybe what I was going on now,
that's, you're busy, it's, and it is,
it isn't just the sheriff
or guys you think here at doing
stuff like that, who consume that?
You know, sometimes it's
people just have no time.
They're very successful and
they have too much money.
But the one thing that you
don't have is time, which is,
and the ability to go and make friends.
- Yeah.
Especially if it's.
- Yeah, it is hard.
Like a lot of people are lonely it's,
especially during the times
of the pandemic as well.
That's like only kind of just
extrapolate extrapolated.
That's only kind of exaggerated.
Yeah.
Exacerbates.
- I feel sorry for a lot of guys,
obviously as a male myself,
(all laughing)
I, you know,
it's one of those things
where you can't really openly talk
about being lonely.
It's quite difficult to do it, you know?
And it's often hard to
just reach out to friends
and be like, Hey man,
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm just lonely, man.
You want to hang out.
- Yeah.
- Like, it's really hard to do that.
And that whole stigma of
like macho insecurity,
- I always want to try and
dispel that and be honest and try
and be open with my are my
emotions and what I'm feeling,
just so that hopefully other people
can be more open with it as well.
Like I feel like when
you're a public figure,
it's kind of your responsibility
to try and improve the
understanding of topics like that I think.
- Generally.
You're allowed to feel emotions.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, bro.
I know.
So, 'cause you know, more often than not,
there is a lot of toxic masculinity
and pride that men have
and especially to be
successful and provide
and you know, basically not be a up.
(Garnt and Connor laughing)
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But this pressure
pressures a difficult man.
I feel like a lot of
guys end up pushing up,
pushing a lot of friends away.
'Cause they're so focused on
trying to not be a failure.
- Yeah.
I feel like, especially with guys,
it's hard to talk about.
It's hard to talk about
something negative.
Like I remember.
Yeah.
I remember like I
remember when we went back
to see all our mates
and we had that Airbnb
where we all caught up.
I remember like going
into like a conversation,
like a deep conversation that
some of our guy mates
were having at the time,
I remember sitting down
on the table and like one
of our mates was talking about,
going through therapy for
one of the things that they went through.
Right.
And you know, more,
more and more people started
sitting like sitting in
and then started sharing their stories
about how they also were
going through something rough,
especially during COVID.
And they had to like
seek therapy about it.
And then eventually we just
had these CR this whole table,
this group of guys,
and I was just like, wait a minute.
Has anyone here not been to therapy?
We look around and nobody
puts their hands up.
And I was like, so wait.
So everyone here has been to therapy.
And I was just like,
how have we never talked about this before
for like four years?
- It's a shame thing, right.
- Yeah.
- Well, people got a lot of
guys feel shame admitting
that they have any of those problems.
- Yeah.
Exactly.
And I'm just like,
if something should be
normalized and not being ashamed
of frowned upon, it's just, it's this,
it's admitting that you have a problem
and you're seeking help for it.
And it's like, I feel like, especially,
especially in England and
especially in Asian culture,
it is very much frowned
upon to like say, Hey,
I went to therapy or I talked to someone
and I was just like,
'cause like the mentality
is that if you go to therapy,
then you're inherently trying
to fix something about yourself.
You're in here.
There's something inherently
wrong about yourself.
- But I think people don't want to admit
that there's something wrong.
Just avoid it.
- Yeah.
And I think that's absolutely.
You know, just speak it,
like try and trying to
keep like a healthy,
like a good mental health is not,
it's not something that should
be frowned upon, you know?
And I feel like America in this,
I like leagues ahead of other
cultures and just accepting
this and...
- Gender doesn't stop you from being sad.
Like if you're sad,
it doesn't matter what you
identify as if you're sad.
And if you need to talk about it,
you need to talk about.
- The, male suicide rate
is so high man, like,
I should have sort of sat
thinking about (indistinct)
- Well male depression
rate is so high as well.
Like no one talks about it.
- Books about thing.
Right?
What I'm saying in my first
year of living in London,
looking back, I could easily
tell you I was depressed.
But at the time, I didn't know.
I didn't know why I was miserable.
I didn't think I was like,
I have no reason to be sad.
So I'm not sad.
- Just because he had
no one to talk about it.
- Yeah.
- (indistinct) a bad mood.
But I also didn't even because
I hadn't been educated on it,
no one even told me that that was like,
who tells you what depression feels like?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] yeah.
- How do you learn that?
I didn't know what it was.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I didn't understand what it was.
And only now when I look
back and I think, oh,
I'd like all the, the
trademarks, if depression, like,
I like didn't want to
hang out with anyone.
But I also was lonely and (indistinct)
- Let us catch 22.
- Yeah.
It's like, it's normally it's
being your own worst enemy,
but I didn't understand that.
And, I'm very, very lucky
that I managed to just
get out of it on my own.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And that now I'm much better.
And I think it was a whole slew of reasons
of why I don't feel that way anymore.
Mainly like just life reasons changing.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But I wish that I'd had more
education on it in school.
Like in Wales, it was never brought up.
Depression was for people who were crazy.
That was not what healthy people
have with normal jobs and wives.
You know, you can't be sad
if you have a job in a wife.
(Connor laughs)
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
- You've got a 50 inch plasma screen TV.
You can't be depressed, (Joey laughs)
Depression is people who killed people.
That's what it was like,
obviously exaggerating.
But yeah, that.
- And I feel at school as well,
like it's hard to take seriously
because of the environment that you're in.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Well, I was just
miserable in school anyway.
Like I, yeah, it's really difficult.
And it's a really uncomfortable
thing to think about.
- Yeah.
- There are times in
my life where I'm like,
oh yeah, I'm there.
So that I was like miserable
and very, very unhealthily.
So very self-destructive.
But I just didn't recognize it.
And I didn't know why.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I guess the main reason is
like why yeah, no one, nothing.
Most of the time, nothing
makes you depressed.
It just happens.
- Yeah.
And I feel like,
it's go going back to what
you're taught in school.
It's just like, oh, the,
seeking help therapy.
Those are for the crazy people.
- Exactly.
- It's just like, you know what?
You don't want to be associated
with the crazies with
some something, you know?
And it's just like, that's just
not how real life is at all.
A lot of people will have a lot of issues
and like some on varying scales,
but there's nothing
wrong with just talking
to someone professional about it.
- There's nothing wrong with seeking help.
- Yeah.
Like, you know, when you've had it
for an extended period of time,
I didn't know.
I was like, well, this is just normal.
This is how I've always felt.
I don't know.
I don't know anything else.
This is what do you mean?
- That's when it starts to get scary.
- Yeah.
because that's all I like for awhile.
That was like how I
just felt all the time.
- Yeah.
- So I was like, oh no,
it was nothing to complain about
because this is how it's always.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause, your memory is very
good at letting you forget
things over a year.
So you very much forget how it was.
- You'll be sued.
You could be,
you'd be surprised how
easy it is for your mind
to just accept things the way they are.
- 100%.
- Now you can get used to a lot of things
and it's scary how you can just get used
to like a lot of like a toxic period
in your life or like a really
bad period in your life.
And your mind just like
accepts that as the norm.
And if you forget that life
could be better, that's you?
That not everyone should feel this way.
- And unfortunately our mind
is a terrible way of
coping with situations.
We don't like.
- Yeah
- And I'll brain is amazing at that.
Like hiding from us.
So for a long time, I
didn't know why we're sad,
but I couldn't figure it out.
Like.
- And he's very good at just like putting
on the emergency handbrake.
Sometimes it'd be like.
- It's really good at like
that little brain is really
good at that (indistinct).
- You really that boy.
- Oh year.
- I employ you to think about it more.
And if you want to get
help, don't be ashamed.
- Don't don't be,
and don't be ashamed to
talk to it about your,
to talk with your classmates about it.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause that's the biggest thing.
I think.
- You're very blessed
to have a good friends.
- Yeah.
- And if you mates don't
take it seriously then,
that's something that's
telling all your mates.
Probably not your mates.
- That's telling.
- Yeah.
That is telling because I've,
I realized then that I was
lucky enough to have mates,
including you guys who I can
talk to anything about this,
and it's not just here,
it's back home as well.
And I'm just like, I got a
pretty good group of friends.
I feel pretty blessed right now know.
- I'm obviously not gonna
bring it up every conversation.
- Yeah.
- You can, bring it up.
- It was a bro moment when I'm just like,
I'm glad we're talking
about this now, man.
- Yeah.
- I want all my friends to feel like
they can come to me in trust
and be like, listen, man,
I'm really struggling.
And I'm like, let's do so let's sit down.
Let's talk about whatever you need, man.
Whatever you need man,
Let's figure it out.
Like let's, do it.
Like I want you to be happy (chuckles).
- Mates don't wanna see mates being sad.
(Garnt laughs)
- Oh man.
You know the one thing that I've learned
as I getting older golf
a bit I'm twenty-five
and I'm saying that it is.
(Joey laughs)
I noticed it is harder to make friends.
It gets, more difficult
to make good friends
because everyone's doing, you know?
- And I feel at that point as well,
everyone already has their
establishment for France.
- Yeah.
And groups and stuff.
And you know, and it's time, man.
(indistinct)
- I remember when I was growing
up, everyone was just like,
time is your most valuable resource.
And I'm just like, fine.
- What does that mean, off.
- Off I'm not (indistinct).
- Give me a million dollars and we'll see
how it buy me a McDonald's meal.
- A time is gonna buy me McDonald's meal.
Okay.
- Shut up, dad.
Logan is opening my (indistinct).
(all laughing)
- It really started to hit me
when I just wanted to
hang out with Sydney.
And now she's like got her
own career and everything.
And we literally have
to like schedule a date.
- Yeah.
- Never had to do before.
And I'm just like what we
have to book out time to spend
time with each other.
- You have to pencil in a date (laughs).
- I have to pencil in time to spend time
with my significant other.
I'm just like, what is there?
What is this?
- Yeah, it is very weird.
- Yeah.
And it's like, time management is a thing
that you have to learn as
you're growing older as well.
And like also,
you just don't have as much
energy as you did before.
Like it's like your energy
levels do like go down
because your patience for.
Just like just, it dwindles, you know.
- I'm like,
I have zero of that now
just like immediately.
I'm like, I'm not gonna waste time on this
because now I know how
valuable my time is.
Like, I finally understand
that time is your most precious values.
- I know right?
- I finally understood after
all the I went to like, oh,
this is what this means.
- And it's not even like, oh,
I could use using this time to make money.
No, you're not.
I mean.
- I could be using this
time to be happy (laughs).
- I can be using this time to hang out
with my homie to play some games, like...
- Anything like but this.
- Like if there's something
that makes me angry nowadays,
it's something that wasted my time.
I'm literally like, literally, like,
I don't have many pet peeves,
but if I feel,
if I do something and I
feel like I could have been,
I could have used that
hour doing something else.
- Yeah.
- I that's the biggest
thing that makes me angry.
- Yeah.
- I could have been like,
I could have been playing
it like a good game.
Could have been hanging
out with my homeys.
- Yeah.
- Have been doing anything.
- Anything, to make me
happier than where I am now.
(all laughing)
- Japanese government and
building (all laughing)
20,000 hours of waiting.
I've had a question in my mind.
That's been haunting me.
- Okay.
- This guy came out of the toilet.
Right.
- Right.
- In the public toilet.
And he flushed the toilet as he left.
When do you flush the toilet?
(Joey laughs)
Because I do you like, because...
- Well, it depends on what you're doing.
- You've done it number two.
Right?
- Okay.
Number two.
- Yu have your, you stand up, right.
You now have two options.
You can start buckling your belt,
putting it back up, putting it,
getting metal ready or
you can flush the toilet.
Which one do you do first.
- While standing up?
- Yeah.
- Because there are some people
who flush while they sit.
- That ain't right.
(Joey laughs)
You know, you just typhoon in your, water.
Like that's terrible.
Well, the circumstance
upon which you are allowed,
I will give the past to be
able to flush the toilet while
still sitting on it.
You know, that smell is so bad that you,
your cheeks are the only thing.
Keeping it in.
- Okay.
I Personally stand up first when I flush.
- Obviously you can 'cause
you're human beings.
- I'm not (indistinct).
- Do you then, right.
So let's say you've unbuckled, right?
Your pets.
'Cause you obviously
you've unbuckled them.
Why?
This has been burning on my
mind because this man did it.
He clearly right.
He clearly got up,
did his pants and then
flushed the toilet and left.
Right?
- Yeah.
- But which one do you do first?
'Cause sometimes I immediately,
I just close the thing,
flush and then something up my pants.
- I buckle up my pants first.
- Then flush that leak.
- Yeah.
- Why am I the weird one?
What happened in my childhood?
- Like, it's weird.
Like the way you do it is weird
because it's that means
you're literally standing
there flushing the toilet with the pants.
- Yeah.
So like this right pants here.
I'll simulate it.
- Okay.
- Say it's like this.
Right?
- Yeah.
I'm like, okay, close the lid, flush.
And then I do this while it's flushing.
- But your pants down, right?
- No.
- Well then that's exact thing.
- Right when I'm like this.
Right.
I come up and then as I'm getting up,
I kind of like pull it
up to the point of light.
Like, it's that?
But I just gotta zip
it up and do the belt.
You don't have you understand what I mean?
You want to send what I mean?
Right.
- No (laughs).
- I don't.
I fail to see the difference.
What's the difference?
- What'd you mean?
- Like what's the difference
between the way you do it and the
way I do it.
- So, when I stand up...
- I like to have a
conversation has gone to or.
- I just sold the cafe.
- We just, had like the
deepest therapy session.
- How do you flush (indistinct).
- This has been on my
mind for like three days.
I just saw someone did it...
- And I need a therapy
session off this conversation.
- Yeah.
- All right.
So, I stand up right.
And I picture it right?
Anyone with any pants doing this?
You pull it up right now.
There's a moment where you can now decide
to wear your pants up.
You're standing up your hands on,
are free for a moment
you can choose to then move your hands
to the zipper and the belt
to fully close your pants.
Or you can flush the toilet.
- Okay.
- I choose to choose to flush.
Oh, I choose to do my
pants and then flush.
- Yeah.
- Like how do we develop these behaviors?
That's what I want to know.
What makes us, why do we do this?
- (laughs) It's deep.
- It's because I would like,
before I flush the flush, right.
Is the, signal that I
have finished everything.
- Yeah.
- Like, 'cause here's the thing.
Here's the thing.
Right?
Sometimes, you're in a public toilet.
I hate the people who like flush.
Like sometimes you're desperate.
You're just like, God, I need to go now.
And you're waiting for something
to come out of the toilets
and here the flush right here,
the flush, or you're just like,
all right,
they're coming out and let's stay in there
for another five minutes
doing God knows what.
- The flushes, like a Pavlovian.
It's like, you hear the flush.
It's all ready to, it just doesn't happen.
- It's just like, if you flush,
you better be coming out of that.
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah.
If you flush,
there must be a ten second window
where you have to get out the toilet.
You're signaling the end of your.
- Yeah.
That's why I want to be fully
ready to get out the moment
I flushed.
- I saw a sprint, man,
- I don't want to keep you guys waiting.
- I'm just wondering,
is there something in my brain
that makes me decide to do that first?
- You're just trolling.
Aren't you?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I do wonder this like psychoanalyze.
- You're like, I want to take my time.
- Like little things I do.
And I wonder like,
why do I do like that?
Why do I do those things?
I don't know.
- Maybe it's a habit you
had since you were a kid.
- Maybe.
Yeah.
- Like maybe when.
- You, did you notice
this in the first place.
- I noticed that this guy immediately left
after he flush.
And I thought to myself, I hold on.
I do like to flush and then
take a moment and just kind of.
- Oh, you're the one
person I would hate to be.
(all laughing)
- You're that awesome
like, give me five minutes.
- The total giant social time.
Doesn't change.
Right.
But the perception of time changes.
- Exactly.
- So you it's 10 seconds
after you flush to us
it's 10 minutes (laughs).
- Overall.
It's the same time I'm spending in there.
So it doesn't matter.
You're going to get into this.
- So to me, if you don't leave the toilet,
by the time the flush is finished,
then you are taking too long.
That is the ESCO, right?
That is, the.
- Because you will sorry
if we covered this on channel before.
I don't know if we have,
how do you prove in public bathrooms?
Do you care about that?
- We haven't.
- I remember in school,
I was always the weird one
because I didn't mind
pooping in the toilets,
but I also was like,
what am I going to do?
- Yeah.
Like to me, it is like a
last resort ruby toilet.
- Yes, yes.
- Yeah.
I've seen crime.
It seems less messy
than that (indistinct).
- One thing I do remember now
that we're talking about this.
When I was back in London,
I went to, I needed the toilet
before I got my train and Euston station.
Now one thing about Euston
station in London is that it's
probably one of the dirtier train station.
They'd say.
- Yeah.
- It's definitely one of the
rougher looking stations.
It doesn't look as nice.
- As this train stations
aren't already dirty.
- Well, I've been King's
cross is pretty nice.
- Yeah.
- It looks pretty fancy.
I'd say.
- One thing, I noticed
after going back was like,
compared to Japan, everything's
doing train stations.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Yeah.
It's true.
Train stations.
Suck in the UK.
Then you don't find out
what platform your train
is on in Houston until
like five minutes before.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So everyone's just standing there.
And then when the thing
comes up, everyone's rushing.
And it's like, why don't
you just tell me it before?
And then I guess there's
some system on their end
where they don't know it's stupid.
They should know.
They should figure this out.
Come on, figure it out.
But, so I went to the
toilet in Houston station
and this was absolute war crimes.
I'm sure some Geneva
conventions are broken.
Then this toilet.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- There was no toilet seat in this toilet.
- This was just the bowl.
- It was just the bowl.
- I've seen that before.
- And I thought it must be a mistake.
I went to, I refuse to go in this one.
It was very busy.
I might...
- (indistinct) someone steal
the lid or something devious.
Like you notice I go to the next one.
It's the same thing.
I go to the next world.
And then now there is now
there is a toilet seat,
but there is like, it is,
it is like something has happened in here.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Not only is the smell apparent,
but like there is like four
pieces of toilet tissue left.
And it's that horrible,
horrible system of like one tissue
that they ration out
that you have to, like,
you have to pull out 50 to
get one wipe with anyway.
It's like, what's wrong with you people?
I get it that you don't want
me to take a out of the role.
I understand that.
But why do you have to make
it such a small amount?
You know what I mean?
Like I, and it's always like half apply.
- Yeah.
- It's like, if I held this up,
I could see through it
and navigate perfectly in a car and a car.
Right?
- Yeah.
- So there's this toilet seat.
Oh, it's terrible.
And then not only that, when you leave it,
I hate when Polly bathrooms do this.
They don't have any soap anywhere.
- Yeah.
- No soap, no way to dry your hands.
And it's like, are you,
you're just telling me not to dry.
You're not telling,
you're just asking me
not to wash my hands.
- Yeah.
- yeah.
- Right?
Like, so I go there, I do the obligatory,
put water on my hands and
leave and I feel dirty stuff.
My hands are wet.
I can't dry that I'm depressed.
Not only was there stains
all over this thing,
that stunk is terrible.
- Yeah.
- Shocking.
How do they not keep these toilets clean?
I don't understand.
- And it's just not getting paid enough.
- You have one job and it just
literally to keep them clean.
I don't think there's
anything else you need to do
in the toilets.
- Well, the thing is that's
why I don't in public,
(Garnt laughs)
(indistinct)
I mean, it's,
there is a big difference
between the toilets,
the toilets in Japan versus
the toilets in the UK.
- Yeah.
- Right?
I mean, as you mentioned last week,
the first thing you noticed
is things are a lot dirtier in the UK.
Well, after you've been living in Japan
for like this long, right?
- Yeah.
Oh, I remembered another story.
(all laughing)
- Go for it.
Go for it.
- Sorry.
I went to this toilet in a coven garden.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So I went to a coffee shop.
Coffee shop was too small.
They didn't have their own toilet.
They used a toilet in coven garden
that was connected to the church.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- And it was 30 Penn center.
It's about 50 cents maybe.
- Yeah.
- And-
- How much were you guys
charged for toilets.
- Oh God.
This toilet was,
it was like, entering some sewer level
and a video game going down these stairs.
So it was in the stairs down.
You just go on the street level,
you have to go down this
really looking 1800s
at architecture.
You get to this like this I'm
kind of Cove looking thing.
It's, this Archway.
Right.
And again, it looks like from something
out of the 1800s that was never replaced.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] yeah.
- Which is amazing, great architecture.
Whoops.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But this is then this is turnstile
and it is the most disgusting color
of orange green wall
that you've ever seen.
And the lights are flickering and yeah.
- It sounds like you're about
to enter a Doxil the level.
- And I'm near certain,
I'm the only person on earth
who actually pay to get in
because the moment I got it,
(indistinct)
I got in two guys just jumped after me.
- Yeah.
- So I go in here.
Right.
And only one of the stalls is open.
So I go in there and I
to do my business now,
unfortunately that was only
like two sheets of toilet roll life.
So I was already,
it was already a bad time by the time.
And there was no bad day, obviously.
- Tragedy.
- So my never quite felt clean.
So I was constantly,
I was also struggling with
that every single day.
- Yeah.
- I definitely felt my was not
clean that January you joked.
But I walked in on many
days thinking like,
holy and need you to
bring a portable today.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] yeah.
- So I'm in this thing, right.
I'm hearing noises from the
two stalls and I'm like,
that's not a big deal.
It's not a big deal.
And then this guy drops a can.
They're kind of ominously
rolls into my store
and it's a kind of Guinness
and I kind of like kick it back
and I'm like, there you go.
He's like, "Cheers."
(all laughing)
And I'm like, hello?
I'm like, okay.
And he's like, it's a
nice day to day in it.
And I'm like,
you talking to me while
I'm in the middle of this.
Like, I me he's like, "Who
else would I be talking to?"
And I'm like, "I don't know."
I'm like what?
And I'm just confused.
I'm like, yeah, it's nice.
So I go out and these two guys come out.
One of them is homeless.
And one of them just looks like,
I don't know who this guy is.
He doesn't look homeless.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But one of the other
guys is clearly homeless.
'Cause his stall was just
had his sleeping bag in it.
- Oh Jesus Christ.
- And I was like, "What
on earth is going on?"
And the guy was like, "You
didn't actually pay for it.
Did you?"
And I was like, "Yeah, I did."
And he was like, "Oh, you're a ticket."
(all laughing)
And then washed his hands and left.
And then the other guy just stared at me.
I was like,
this is the most comfortable
toilet experience I've had.
I was just happy.
- [Garnt] Oh God.
- I thought I was gonna die.
And then I was like,
okay, I'm just going to go through.
And I just worked the toured
sandwich of depressed,
like some kind of emergency
meeting button X to get out.
It was horrible.
- The kicking back the Guinness
can just sounds like an event in a game.
It was wait, this is how
you activate the store.
(all laughing)
- I heard something drop.
- Yeah.
- And then it had that really
ominous noise of rolling came
over and I was like, kicking it,
like take it back.
I don't bunch with kidneys.
- [Man] It's a side quest in Yakuza.
- Yeah.
(indistinct)
Because the side quest.
- I, this short I'll take a.
- Jesus.
- If there's one place,
I don't want to have a conversation.
It's on the not, not, not, you know,
maybe if we're in some kind of
Ritz, Carlton, toilet, wets,
it's amazing hand towels.
- [Connor and Joey] Yeah.
- You know, when you're in a fancy place,
that's their tissues.
There's towels.
There's a pile of towels
to wash your hands.
That's actually how my day is, how is it?
I'm just enjoying the fun
selection of towels, SERPs,
and moisture.
And it looks, you know, it's great.
That then talks to me (laughs).
But when I'm in the
sketchiest toilet in London,
no thank you.
- (indistinct) next to you.
- I didn't know.
This guy had his whole set up in there.
I was like, oh my God.
I've been like, I don't know.
I don't know if that's okay.
But I mean,
I'm glad you've got some accommodation
for now, but like, me.
- Yeah.
- Jesus Christ.
- Scary.
And I just didn't know
why they called me a.
I paid for it. I should
I be a good citizen?
Know someone has to stock the toilet paper
or else they're gonna afford it.
- That's the only like
bad public toilet stories
that has happened to you because like...
- Like when I went back.
- Oh, when you went back,
that's why you just don't in public.
In the UK, at least in Japan.
It's okay.
(indistinct)
- Okay.
No, no, it's not.
No, it's not in Japan.
There is a common phenomenon in Japan.
If you go to some places at night,
there was a big thing where
dudes try and watch your PP.
If you've had, have you
seen the videos on Twitter?
- No.
- You've seen them.
There's loads of videos, right?
In certain areas.
I think there are very,
more likely to happen.
There's videos of dudes
like jacking off in urinals,
like right next to other guys.
You're just seeing this.
- [Man] No.
- Oh my God.
- I mean, I've heard stories about this.
- I've seen this on Twitter.
- I'm not Surprised by this.
- I've never been a lot
of stories of like dudes,
like, looking at it and
stopping, looking at it.
And that's apparently
somewhat common in Japan.
- I mean, I'm not surprised at all.
This is Japan.
- Common.
- It is also, you know what I mean?
When you, kind of treat your treat,
gay people kind of harshly here.
- Yeah.
- Just stuff like that.
I guess they have no choice.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- Don't feel comfortable,
but it's still strange.
- Yeah.
- I've had friends who
had happened to hear.
- Really?
- Yeah.
Well they've just started like pull it out
and going at it.
- Oh my God.
(indistinct)
- Sorry.
In which, areas I want to know.
(indistinct)
Okay, well I'm sketchy parts sheets.
There are some sketchy parts in Shinjuku.
(indistinct)
- I have seen, there has
been a couple of instances
where I have seen dudes
in public jacking it.
- Yeah, they do it.
It's not weird.
It's not always,
it's not unusual to see.
- Unfortunately it's not unusual to see.
And it's definitely scarring.
- Yeah.
- Having a Georgie Strausser Shinjuku.
And then it's like, oh, just
jacking in the alleyway.
- We don't normally hang out
at those like kind of like establishment.
So it doesn't really
surprise me that area.
But like, yeah.
I mean most public toilets
in Japan are like cleaner
than like most people's private toilets.
It's rediculars.
Like the concept of clean
public toilets didn't exist
in my mind until I went to Japan.
I'm just like, wait.
- I've seen some really
dirty ones in Japan.
- Oh, yeah.
Occasionally there is some way.
- Occasionally it happens.
But normally you never
see clean public toilets,
especially in England and
especially in Thailand as well.
My God Southeast Asia.
Okay.
I achieve.
Wait, wait, wait.
I actually realized going back why?
I don't like days.
Right?
And it's because I realized, oh,
I've grown up my entire
life with birthdays
because Southeast Asia
have their own days.
- [Man] What?
- But okay.
Because, but in Southeast Asia,
we have this thing that,
which we call a bad day,
but it's not a bad day.
It's a hose.
All right.
So.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Now I'm civilised.
- (indistinct) in Japan,
you have (laughs).
- Toshiba's system, the measures,
the moisture of your to
deliver the perfect blend.
- So read the reason I
hate the feeling of bodies
is because my entire life
I've had like Southeast Asian bodies,
which is just like every
toilet has like this hose.
Right.
You know, how in the
buddies in Japan is like
this precision sniper.
- I was being shot at your hole.
It's not political down.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- In Southeast Asia,
you have this host put a shotgun.
It's like a shotgun
that you shot gun your entire house.
- How did you use this?
If you're like, you know, you're,
are you on the toilet?
- You're on a toilet slow.
So you have to like put
the hose between your legs.
(indistinct)
- Yeah.
- Which is still weird.
- [Man] It's like, what
the fuck is the wet?
Why is it always wet?
(all laughing)
- I don't want to be
reminded of a theme park
when I'm going to the toilet.
I don't want that.
- And so like a lot of public
toilets in Southeast Asia,
you see the toilet seat and it's wet
and it's not wet from.
It's just wet from the day.
Right.
And so that's why, that's what I, like.
I think I've been grained
that into my mind to be like,
yeah, that feeling of water on your.
That's bad feeling.
- I've tried to I've.
Okay.
I like how we've just managed to go
from deep to the again.
I apologize.
I'm sure we'll run out of
topics to talk about with this.
Eventually I, in Japan,
sometimes you do come
across the old style toilets
of Japanese starlets.
- Yeah.
Have you ever used them?
The waspy toilet?
- Well, I'll talk you about it.
Yeah.
So it was you just AKA
a hole in the ground
and you squat over it and you just do it.
- Yeah.
- Now I have used it one time
and I just could not get over the feeling
that I was just kind of dropping something
that was just going to splash everywhere.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] yeah.
- And I could not get over that feeling.
I was squatting real low,
but I just, I couldn't,
I did not enjoy it.
It was not fun.
- What I hate about those.
'Cause I've had to use
that plenty of times
as well in Southeast Asia.
Especially like,
especially if you're on a long drive.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Like if you, need to your business,
every public toilet,
is that holding on the ground.
- Yeah.
- If, it came to it and the only option
I had is that a hole in the ground?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I'm sure I'm in a hole in the ground.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Can I have it?
I bought, if I can,
I will obviously go for the premium wall
mass bid day blasting.
What temperature moistening experience
any day of the week I would choose.
- The thing that makes
me most uncomfortable
is like with a normal toilets.
There's the seat.
And the seat is like a safety barrier,
nothing penetrates this barrier.
Right?
- So I liked that.
I couldn't miss.
I've never missed the toilet.
(all laughing)
(indistinct)
- Hey bro.
You have to play like
mini-golf we're there.
But like if you miss the whole,
he got to clean that up.
(Garnt laughs)
- Total paper and scoop it in.
What happens.
Does anyone know?
Is Eric, is there a courageous?
- You don't miss.
- I have gone 25 years or
probably like 23 without missing.
I'm very happy to keep my streak alive.
- Yeah
- Yeah.
- I don't want to even attempt to miss.
And also I just like
sitting down I'm lazy.
- Yeah.
- I don't like that.
You know, you you're propping yourself up
with your own legs.
'Cause if you don't
then, and you fall over.
- I don't do exercise.
- Supposedly it's supposed
to be better to squat.
Like just like, that's what I say.
It's less likely you're
going to get hemorrhoids
and (indistinct).
Like.
- But if we just stop at McDonald's,
but I still do a lot of things
that are better for me that.
- True, true.
Why did we get on this topic?
(all laughing)
- I'm so sorry.
This is my fault.
I was just, he was on my mind.
Okay.
And I thought, I didn't
bring it up (indistinct)
- Was it on your mind this entire time.
- Spent on mindful of three days,
I saw the men do it and I
woke up thinking about it.
- I'm also very used to just like
in a hole in the ground
from like going camping in Australia
because (indistinct) we have long drops
and it's just like, it's literally.
- No, that's just, well,
she just do that anyway.
- Yeah.
- But when you're camping,
you have no choice.
- Yeah, exactly.
Because it's a hole in the ground.
But it's like, it's not like
a shallow hole in the ground.
And it's like a real deep hole.
- Oh, really should dig.
When we used to go camping,
we'd dig up tiny hole and fill it up.
- Oh no.
Those ones where it's like.
- What are you doing?
- No, no, no, no, no.
It's like ones that have
built into the campsite.
- Oh.
- Like in a cabin.
- Oh, they made an outhouse,
- Yeah, like an outhouse space.
- Outhouse.
- Yeah.
But it's like a wooden log cabin
and you walk in and
it's just a whole, it's.
- An outhouse.
- And you like put your
torch in it and it's like,
you can't see the bottom.
(indistinct)
- Yeah.
That's an outhouse.
Yeah, exactly.
And yeah, I had to do those.
- Okay.
This is the worst experience of my life.
All right.
So picture it.
You're skiing.
You have those ski boots home.
- Yeah.
Okay.
- All right.
So have you ever have you want ski boots?
Actually.
- [Man] Oh, yeah.
- It is impossible to
have precision movement
in the ski boots.
Right.
- You also like a roadblocks.
- Right?
So you do, you bought
like you're in roadblocks.
(Connor chuckles)
So the only option at this
particular skiing place
for some reason was a port-a-potty.
- Okay.
- Can you imagine a
port-a-potty in ski boots?
It doesn't work, right?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you need to sit down.
You got to aim yourself.
You gotta have room to close the door.
Right.
That was bad enough that it
was a port-a-potty I thought,
oh my God,
I gotta get used a port-a-potty
and ski thing and ski boots.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
I get in this Porter potty.
I think it was in,
might've been Bulgaria.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I get in this Porter potty.
I don't know how this has happened.
There is, toilet roll with on it,
on the roof, on the sides.
On every, it looks like
some kind of someone
has tried to do you use
like ancient talismans
of on this port-a-potty
to get spirits away.
It is.
I immediately threw up
when I got in there.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Because I was still
needed to go somewhere.
I stuck with it.
But right after I was done, I threw up,
it was so disgusting.
I'd never seen anything like it,
I was, it was almost like a trap
that they put that for tourists.
(Joey laughs)
There was like, you,
tourists coming to our place.
It was horrible, man.
You go into this thing.
It's tiny.
Right?
- Yeah.
- You can barely sit there.
Your ski boots, belly fitted.
So your knees are touching the door.
That also has on them.
I don't know how that
would happen to this day.
I still don't know why.
- They should apologize viewers.
You have to listen to this.
- It's disgusting.
It was, oh God.
- That's what my thoughts were.
Like.
- That's why, I flushed the toilet down.
- That's why, that's why I never shot.
Like when I was in high school too.
'Cause like my high school,
because I went to an all boys school.
- Yeah.
- Right.
So obviously there's
going to be some afoot,
(Garnt laughs)
like in places where there's going to be
in places where they shouldn't be.
- That was always the pranks were there.
- There was always the pranks.
And I'm like guys like
where we're not animals.
- The people shooting in urinals.
- Oh dude.
I don't think there was ever a day
where I went to the urinal.
There wasn't in it.
Like it was actually discussed.
- (indistinct) to the different cups.
- I'm like.
- [Man] Even in South-East
Asia we're kinda like...
- Yeah, it was, it was gross.
I'm like, yeah.
- Never.
Whoa, whoa.
Humans show disgusting.
- I dunno.
- Why?
Why can we not properly?
(laughs)
Apparently.
- Toilet training is alive.
- 2000 years to get this right.
- And we're still.
We're only one step ahead.
I was just.
- Sitting in the hole in the ground.
God dumb it.
- How do we always talk about shooting?
- Okay.
I really didn't want to.
I wanted.
- To get away from anyone like eating.
- Whether they get away from me.
I didn't want you to
stay to be the podcast,
but it also been on my mind.
(Joey laughs)
I'm done.
There's no more.
Now I promise you.
Won't talk about for 10 episodes.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- I ain't going to make that promise, man.
- I promise.
- I'm going to bring it on.
First thing next episode.
- No.
- Just to break the rule.
- I will not engage.
(indistinct)
And in such an uncivilized
manners on this podcast,
we are a civilized podcast
with two Australians,
one Australia, two Brits,
and should be civilized.
(all laughing)
- But you know who normally?
- Oh my God, here we go.
- Have patience.
Amazing.
Definitely don't because they watch us.
(all laughing)
- They definitely bonus points.
If you're listening to this on the toilet,
that's a the true trash
Stacy's experience.
Right?
- Shout out to all the Southeast Asian
who knows about the hose day,
(Joey and Connor laughing)
who grew up that's that still like.
- Gone.
Whenever we need to
increase his popularity.
(indistinct)
- Hey, sound these stations, these.
(all laughing)
(indistinct)
- I'm just trying to bring
the Southeast Asian culture
to the mainstream.
(Joey laughs)
People need to know what it's like.
Okay.
- Hello.
How are you doing?
- How are you?
But Hey, if you like to smoke the show,
they go to page on low
cost slash trash days.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send this you means on the Sabrina.
And if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
- Wow.
But yeah, go on.
- Thank you.
- Again, I love how trash tastes,
the only show where we
can go from deep self-help
conversation to how do you ship?
- Yeah.
- I feel, I feel like we need to have
like our like say monthly
or bimonthly therapy
session with the boys.
And then it was like, okay.
- And then Immediately
falling off with (indistinct).
(Garnt laughs)
- And it was just like,
all right out of our system.
All right.
- Yeah.
Great back to poop.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I'm sorry.
That was really poor timing of it.
- It wouldn't be trash stays with them.
- Well, thank you patrons.
And everyone else watching bye guys.
I guess.
- [Garnt and Joey] Bye.
(upbeat music)